this is Jocko podcast number 222 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening someone called
for my Afghan interpreter Rahman a good
man with whom we had worked with for
some time these interpreters are the
unsung heroes of the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan they often suffer threats
and ostracism for their willingness to
endure the battlefield alongside us
their motivation isn't money there isn't
enough money to make it worthwhile
facing down insurgents who know where
you and your family live they are
idealists they work and risk death
because they believe in our common cause
of freedom Rahman responded to the call
immediately running before me his foot
fell in a particular spot just two feet
away from where I stood I was looking
right at him as I later discovered he
instantly lost all his limbs in the
explosion even though I was staring
right at him I never actually saw it
happen my experience was a series of
tremendous blows and subsequent
realizations a train hit me ears ringing
what the [ __ ] was that
darkness something is wrong
got hit my legs reach down and see if
they're still there they're there I feel
them pain everywhere mostly my abdomen
something shot through it I think my
eyes must be caked with mud I can barely
see anything I hear groaning and
screaming someone hit an ie D pain
everywhere but my eyes I crawl around a
little bit mostly to see if my body
still functions my teammates make their
way to me I asked someone to pour water
on my eyes to remove the dirt so I can
see that doesn't work
I can only see light and in some shapes
must be a lot of dirt I recognized my
Corman's voice as he works on my wounds
I say dude don't get blown up it sucks
he laughs and tells me to shut up
I was conscious throughout our corpsman
stopped my bleeding the worst of which
was from my knees and wrapped up my eyes
it still did not occur to me that there
was anything wrong with them I could
only hear the situation around me my
teammates calling to each other
communicating the situation with tense
voices I later found out that a foot
wearing the typical Salomon boot that we
all wore hit one of my teammates in the
chest about 50 yards away Rahman was
groaning in pain deep deep pain most
people's experience of combat wounds is
from the movies a soldier gets hit his
guts spilling out and he looks down at
them screaming in horror but this is not
the way it is in reality truly bad
injuries SAP your energy and prevent you
from screaming instead the sound of
wounded man makes is a much deeper more
visceral emanating from the depths of
his being
it's a groan a cry a moaning that reeks
of utter desperation it is far worse
than a scream it is true pain manifested
in the sound this was the sound that
Rahman made it is unforgettable
as the quorum intended to me and we
waited for the medevac helicopter a
thought entered my head we may be in a
firefight any second now Rahman was
barely alive and he would later die in
the hospital
our EEO d chief petty officer took a
little Fraggle Sol and would be
evacuated with us all hands were needed
to fight I could hear the medevac helo
coming in low this was no time to ask
someone to carry me blown up and blind I
stood up and walk myself to it
Dave warson who would be killed two
months later heroically laid down cover
fire for me as I boarded the helo there
was my last memory of him
medics onboard the helicopter took one
look at me laid me down and eased me
into unconsciousness I woke up days
later far away from Helmand far away
from Kandahar far away from my brothers
and arms far away from the war and dust
of Central Asia I was brought back into
consciousness in Germany at the American
at the American Hospital long store a
breathing tube was being unceremoniously
ripped from my throat rather unpleasant
I opened my eyes or thought I did and
saw nothing a physician came to me and
told me the truth my right eye was gone
my left eye was so heavily damaged that
there was virtually no chance I would
see with it again
my future was a future of blindness of
darkness of no sight no color no visual
beauty I would never see a sunset a
friend a loved one again in one instant
in a fatal footfall all that was ripped
away
and that right there was an excerpt from
a book called fortitude written by Dan
Crenshaw who is a former SEAL officer
and he's actually been on this podcast
before number 118 and the last time he
was on he was in the process of running
for Congress well he won and is
currently a congressman serving the 2nd
congressional district of Texas in the
House of Representatives and well it's
an honor to have Dan back with us today
to share some of the lessons learned
that he talks about in his new book and
once again the name of the book is
fortitude Dan thanks for coming back man
hey thank you for having me listen do
you read that I was like maybe I should
have asked you to read my book in the
audio version that was good
well thanks it's uh it's only good
because the story that's being told is
is obviously a very powerful one and you
know you sent me this book and as soon
as you sent it to me
I started talking to you about let's get
you back on the podcast obviously you're
a busy man obviously you're busy man
right now for reference it is what is it
it's March of 2020 in the midst of the
pandemic the corona virus pandemic is
going on around the world and around
America there's schools and again who
knows what this will look like looking
back on it when people are listening to
sin the future whether if they're
listening to in a month from now a week
from now or years from now it'll be
interesting what this pandemic turns out
to be but you braved the travel we did
we did and we just you know I'm leaving
off the heels of that late night vote
again for for listeners trying to put
this in context and what you saw in the
news leaving off the heels of that late
night vote where where which was for the
economic stimulus that the the president
supported and was bipartisan in nature
different from the eight billion plus
dollars that we voted on a week prior
which was meant to combat it on a public
health scale so you know I it's every
everybody agrees I think we've as a
country and as a government we have
taken this particular pandemic more
seriously than anything in the past more
than we did for Ebola or for h1n1 and
I've asked that specific questions to
folks like the assistant Surgeon General
Admiral red who have worked all of these
pandemics and so I just hope people
realize that that's not what you hear
from the media you know the media would
tell you that it's so totally unprepared
and you know you're never going to be
perfectly prepared I think that's a
lesson you and I know pretty well yeah
but you learn those lessons and you do
better than next time
the finger-pointing has been completely
unnecessary
mostly dishonest and totally unhelpful
but the government has been taking it
pretty seriously and we're definitely
taken it seriously in Congress well I'm
glad you were able to get out here and
again I think there's no telling what
this will look like in hindsight but
it's quiet around here in San Diego
right now there's just not a lot of
people doing a lot of stuff obviously
we're we're in the gym and the gym you
know not a lot not a ton of people
coming into gym right now there's still
people training though don't worry it
worked we're training that jiu-jitsu but
yeah you sent me the book and you know
cracked it open started reading it and
immediately was just you know getting in
touch with you to see if we could get
you out here on the podcast to talk
about it and man you know the the stuff
that you've been through and the lessons
that you've taken away from it are very
powerful and you know that's one of the
things that struck me out of the gate is
that when you got wounded you actually
you actually drew strength from very
powerful place and things that you've
been through and I want to jump in and
read some more of this um some more of
this things that you've been through and
I think a lot of people are gonna be
able take a lot away from it so I'm
going back to the book this is after you
wounded I fought back to another time in
my life two decades earlier the first
time I ever witnessed the kind of
inescapable pain that I was feeling now
and the grit to overcome it was with my
mother she fought a battle so many other
modern women fight breast cancer and she
did so with endurance Grace and optimism
her example has never left me and I
wasn't about to let some cheap-ass AED
in the ancient killing fields of
Afghanistan render me unworthy of her
memory she was only 35 years old when
she was diagnosed same age as me as I
write these words when she got the news
it was one day before my little
brother's first birthday I was five
years old the doctors told her she might
have five years to live and they were
right soon after she would be feeling
the pain I was feeling now as the cancer
and chemotherapy ripped apart her body
in battle she fought it for five years
and when I was ten she died if you've
ever cared for a loved one in terminal
decline you know what that's like
there is an intensity of loss that is
immeasurable words don't do it justice
the whole deep down in your gut feels
like it will never go away as a child
the intensity of the experience is made
worse as grief is amplified by
incomprehension going from kindergarten
to fourth grade knowing that your mother
is dying that the center of a small
boy's world is collapsing is an
experience I wouldn't wish on anyone but
from this grief came learning I got to
experience the nature of a true hero and
the example she set was the most
powerful fortifying and selfless thing I
have
scene including combat buying helpless
in a hospital bed I had to wonder
whether my mother had asked the same
desperate question I was currently
asking would I ever see my family again
I figured that if she could suffer
through that question and the unknowable
answer so could I my mother spent half a
decade staring death in the face burned
with caring for two small boys whom she
would not live to see grow up
she lived day to day in ever-increasing
pain the cancer afflicted her and the
cancer treatments afflicted her to six
rounds of chemotherapy on top of
radiation treatments are a brutal
experience for even the strongest
constitution self-pity is never a useful
state but if anyone had reason to feel
sorry for herself and had to complain a
bit it was my mom but she never did in
terminal decline and in pain across five
years I never heard her complain once I
never heard her bolon her fate I never
saw her express self-pity every day she
woke up was a day she was still alive
and she lived she was dying and she was
grateful to not be dead yet every extra
day was a gift where she could look her
boys in the face every next evening was
another night she could tell us she
loved us before bed even during her last
days when the hospital delivered her
deathbed and hospice nurse to our dining
room her demeanor did not change Susan
Carol Crenshaw was exactly the opposite
of what she had every right to be
brutal yeah yeah that was more for my
mom than for me you know I tell that
story because well that the name of that
chapter is perspective from darkness and
perspective I think is something we lack
in our modern-day society we are I think
too many people are willing to jump to
this false conclusion that you've had it
the worse that your life is worse than
your ancestors or than your peers or
than anybody else walking around America
right now and there's just a really just
so happens there's a really good chance
that's not true
I'm not saying it's not true I'm just
saying there's a pretty good chance
that's probably not true it's
interesting too I always talk about
perspective from a leadership
perspective which means hey if I'm
looking at one of my troops the better I
understand their perspective on what I'm
telling them and what their job is and
what the mission is the better I'm gonna
be able to lead them and same thing with
my boss the better I understand my
boss's perspective and what the strategy
looked like and what's the overall thing
he's trying to get accomplished the
better I understand his perspective the
better I'm gonna be able to lead and
it's interesting cuz when you put that
across society you would think that in
today's day and age with the a bit with
social media with the ability to absorb
as so many other people's perspectives
you'd think that that would open up your
mind yeah to realize that that there's
you know a lot of other people that that
have been through much worse than then
anything I've even been close to gone
through yeah and yet it doesn't seem to
be happening that way no and I mean one
of the most popular stories for an
American to hear you know is is a story
of overcoming adversity and that's a
good thing I'm glad those are still the
the stories that are the most popular in
the American psyche you know that a
movie about somebody who's downtrodden
and overcomes it it's still a good movie
but there there is it's undeniable that
there is this fragility
is infecting America and that's that's
why I wrote this book and it's um you
know it's not a political book it's not
a sealed book it's not a it's it's a
cultural book it's it's a cultural
philosophy book and it's it's it's
simultaneously an individual kind of
self-help book and just how to be
mentally tougher in your own individual
life but there are much broader cultural
implications that are strewn throughout
the book it is a it is a culture book
and because I fear that we are getting
more sensitive more more prone to
microaggressions and prone to saying how
offended you are and wearing wearing
that offense on your sleeve proudly and
and and this gets to the I think what's
the the next chapter which is who is
your hero and we've changed what we look
up to like we think that it's good to to
scream about how offended we are that's
becoming like a a moniker of a good
thing you know it's interesting as as
you know before we started recording you
know we're just talking about kind of
life in the games and and if there's one
thing that you never do in the teams and
ever is show anyone that you're offended
by anything that you're saying to you
because if you allow that to happen you
know you're gonna get torn apart whereas
it seems like and I hadn't thought about
from that perspective the all the rage
in the public right now is if you can
possibly get offended by something then
it's you're you're the you're the best
thing in the world you know jump up and
down and point to the person that
offended you and why you were offended
and and the more offended you are the
better off the aggrieved victim status
is supreme these days and that's a and
that's more of a serious problem than
then I think most Americans are giving
it credit for like it's a really bad
thing because you're changing you're
changing our heroes and and when I say
heroes I want to want to be more
specific cousin and I outlined this in
the book in greater detail I don't mean
like Jaco is my hero I don't actually
and I person when people asked me about
who I look up to and my heroes I I will
tell them attributes of people that I
think are respectable
don't think you should have one person
that you look up to I don't think that's
totally healthy and that's not what I'm
talking about in the book I'm talking
about hero archetypes you know in an
archetype is a is a is a broader set of
ideas or attributes that we sort of that
we sort of recognize collectively okay
that's it's more of a psychological term
than anything else and there are certain
hero archetypes you know like the Navy
SEALs have a hero archetype when we
write about that in our in our SEAL
ethos it's such a beautifully written
ethos and I and I have the entire thing
written in the book because it perfectly
demonstrates what we believe we should
be now what we should do but what we
should be and that's a really
interesting thing and I and I and I know
that you look at a corporate ethos and
if you go to people like corporations
websites and you read them there they're
usually something like we want to be the
number one manufacturer on the west
coast it's like that's not who you want
to be that's just something you want to
do if you if you write out an ethos of
who you want to be you can you can reach
that level of elitism you can surpass
mediocrity so that's important that's
important thing is here is that we have
societal hero archetypes that we look up
to Jesus is a is a hero archetype
Superman is a hero archetype real
characters too you know I put I could
name a thousand you know Rosa Parks
Ronald Reagan these all of these people
embody certain attributes that the
American people think this is good okay
man we generally agree on these things I
tell the whole story in the book about
about when I was at Disney World or was
it Disneyland it was Disney World and I
was at the Star Wars land and I was
watching this really cool thing happened
where they where they let these kids do
Jedi training and of course like in
typical Disney fashion everything is
really well run the actors are
absolutely amazing and they're teaching
these kids you know how to work their
swords and all that but they're also
teaching them really cool things like
just little Jedi lessons like like will
you let your emotions be driven by hate
and anger you know like really simple
because we look up to the Jedi as like a
hero archetype and so there are certain
things that are just viewed as good but
that's changing and I and I find that to
be an extremely dangerous thing because
we're the aggrieved victim the person
who talks about being offended the most
and who screams the loudest were
elevating that person to a higher level
in our society and that's dangerous
you're flipping cultural norms on their
head and you do that at your own peril
you know and ends you know cultural
foundations based in thousands of years
of trial and error and wisdom those are
important they're more important than
people realize and like that's that's
that's frankly what the first I guess
well that that particular chapter is
about perspectives chapter you know
they're all related of course but the
perspectives chaffed and the reason I
bring up my mom and the reason I tell
that story and then subsequent stories
of of other guys that we've lost is
because you you need to it's healthy to
go through life thinking you know what
somebody has hard had it harder than me
and I'd like to live up to their memory
I'd like to live up to that hero
attribute the hero that are the hero
archetype of my mother and I'm not lying
she never complained she just never did
and if she did I didn't hear it as a kid
and so when you're living in blindness
and not sure whether you will see again
it's healthy to have that in your head
and I mean I say you don't have to uh
you don't have to experience a bomb in
your face to get some perspective but
you can read about it and it's like you
said earlier in a world where we're so
connected and we can see everybody
else's story of hardship you would think
that we would have more perspective but
but it seems that the opposite is true
and first steps of reversing that trend
I think is to at least realize it yeah
we we recently had on Rose Schindler who
was a house where it's survivor and I
got many many many messages and comments
coming back saying yeah
myself in check you know I I don't have
it that bad
so that and yet we've had many people on
here that have been through some really
hellacious things whether it's prisoner
war camps just devastating situations
and it is it's it's it if they weren't
here to here I get the feeling sometimes
that if people weren't hearing it here
they wouldn't be hearing it they
wouldn't be hearing it you know they'd
just be thinking that everyone is living
better than they are and they're the
ones that are in the worst possible
situation in the world we've got yeah
that's a you know I don't bring it too
much to politics but it is it is it is
one reason that we that we have lurched
into this conversation about socialism
because fundamentally socialism is as an
ideology that pits people against each
other you have to believe that somebody
else is oppressing you and that they
have it better than you for you to
embrace socialism it is it is envy it is
the ultimate sin manifested into a
political ideology not the ultimate sin
but it's one of them and that's I was
I'm always looking for the deeper reason
as to why something is happening and it
is natural for for people to want to
believe that something outside their own
power is fact is affecting their lives
because if it's you if it's your fault
if it's you who has to step up that's
harder it's much easier to believe that
there's something else it also is an
assault on your ego when you look at
yourself and you say well I guess I'm
the one that messed this up yeah it is
and that's that's a devastating
psychological consequence when your ego
is hurt that way it is yeah I wrote a
book about that called extreme ownership
it's good but again it's it's one of
those things where you know you wrote
this book as you know as you're saying
like a cultural philosophy you know life
and I wrote extreme ownership as well as
leadership principles but I mean it well
it didn't take but two seconds for
everyone to say oh yeah what you're
talking about is you know easily
transforms into a into a cultural
philosophy of taking ownership and
responsibility for what's going on in
your
absolutely there's no doubt about it and
you find yourself in the lot in light
and look do people get cancer yes people
get cancer to do horrible things happen
to people to families yes absolutely how
do you respond to those things is the
question how do you take ownership of
what you do next and and that's the
that's the big difference and if what
you do next is is you know say it's out
of my control and I can't do anything
and your get the mentality that you're a
victim of what's happening around you
that means you're not gonna make any
changes to transform your life and move
in a more positive direction it's just
the way it is and you know I think I
think one of these things that happens
with you know these ideas behind
socialism in America and again it's it's
like crazy that we would be sitting here
talking about this anybody that anybody
that reads anything about history knows
that this is just not good but you know
it comes across always as hey well what
we want to do is help everyone out
that's what we want to do we want to
help everyone out and okay if that's
like the core belief and this is where I
think sometimes we could do better or
you know someone like myself could do a
better job explaining to people look if
you care about other human beings so
much if you want to help as many people
as possible in this country the best
possible thing you could do is allow the
market to flourish allow people to build
businesses that's what you that's what
changes people's lives that that's what
helps not get giving them a handout and
making them reliable or a reliant on the
state right it doesn't help anybody it
helps them for a week you know it helps
them for that pay period but it doesn't
help them transform their lives into
something more positive when one way I
explained that exact sentiment is to ask
someone to imagine how they would raise
their kid if they love their kid you
know would you give them whatever they
want would you would you tell your kid
that whatever they do wrong it's it's
not their fault somebody else made them
do it wrong would you tell them that
there's no consequences for their
actions would you tell them that if they
do an hour of chores and their sibling
does three hours
that they deserve the same reward and
would you teach them any of these things
there is no liberal who would teach at
their kids these things they don't
because they love their kids and they
want their kids to be successful but
that's effectively what we're teaching
what we're saying that we should teach
our citizens and so I ask people why
don't we treat our citizens the way we
treat our kids as if we loved them
because that's true compassion it
doesn't mean we don't have a social
safety net right and that's always the
counter-argument it's a disingenuous
counter-argument well the
counter-argument to that is look with
your kids
and this is an example that I use when I
especially when I'm talking to
businesses so I say listen like what
will be with a start-up right that's
grown from you know they were ten people
then there are hundred people now
they're getting to that threshold and I
say listen at some point you're gonna
have to put some discipline on what's
going on inside of your company you're
gonna have to have people come to work
and that aligned times you're gonna have
to have them eat lunch at certain times
not just like you're gonna have to
you're to have to have meetings and that
are scheduled and look when you've got a
company of twelve people you can get
away with all that stuff there and it's
great there's money coming in and
everything's but as soon as you start to
grow well you have to start to have
discipline inside your organization
right and so the example I give people
is I say listen have you ever met a kid
that when he's when he's born look when
a when a child is born you give whatever
they want you got to keep them alive
right there's your social state like you
have to give them food water milk you
have to get you have to feed them you
have to take care of them if you
continue to do that when they're three
four five well by the time they're ten
you actually now have Satan for a child
yeah because this kid is totally out of
control
do demanding doesn't it not only is
totally demanding but doesn't know how
to do anything for themselves can't make
them solve the sandwich can't tie their
own shoes it can't do anything so what
you have to do is you have to let people
fend for themselves you have to let kids
brush up against the guardrails of
failure you you have to do that and yes
you have to do that with society as well
in my opinion and that's what that's
what the thing the argument that I don't
hear back at people that are saying hey
we should give everything away for free
is listen for that we don't have enough
to give away everything for free right
the best way that you can take care of
the most amount of people is to allow
freedom allow individual freedom allowed
people to pursue goals allow people to
pursue business allow people to grow
things and hire people that's how you
that's how we all win it's so it's crazy
to me that we still have these
discussions and it's also yeah it's
crazy to me that we're having these
discussions right now like this there's
like this belief that they subscribe to
which is if only politicians want so
mean and corrupt you know there's all
these things hidden that we could just
give you but they don't want to and I
most like does that really sound right
like this is that does that really sound
like that's that's correct that was just
all just extra money just hidden in the
in the in the Treasury that we could
just give out what we don't want to that
everybody that we have all these luxury
apartments that we could just give out
you know because housings are right or
whatever or that or that there's just
enough doctors and hospitals to take
care of everyone and they're just kind
of waiting around like not you know I
mean like come on you know it's it's not
if something if it sounds too good to be
true it most certainly is and again it
doesn't mean that we don't want to keep
striving for a you know broader access
to health care it doesn't mean that we
want to keep don't want to keep striving
for a or efficient social safety net not
saying that but the but they lurch to
the to the progressive left and
socialism is it's it's it's based upon
this idea that that we're keeping
something from you and it's just not
true it's based on this idea to that
that that where do I want to go with
this it's it's kind of like a constant
escalation of crisis and it's it's it's
not surprising that we got there okay
and this is what I mean by that if
you're a progressive you're generally
wanting more progress right change for
the sake of change itself is often the
case and you have to promise more things
than you did last time
right because fundamentally
it's it's it's based in the sense of
compassion you know giving people things
from the government they don't think
very much they don't think much more
about what that does to the foundation
of the creation that you talked about
it's just giving me four more things and
it's almost like they relied on
conservatives for the last hundred years
to at least to at least be an obstacle
to their to their worst instincts right
because the goods conservatives are the
ones who say okay hold on like ease
think of the second third order
consequences of that think of what that
does to our foundations
when I say foundations I mean
foundations of a free-market system that
creates all this wealth in the first
place like you can't you can't just you
can't remove the legs of the stool if
you want to improve the stool I get it
let's work on that but don't remove the
legs of the stool it'll just fall same
with our political foundations same with
our cultural foundations there's three
groups that are very important we can I
could go on for hours about this but but
I'll try and stay on top on this line of
thought here and so you promise more
things and you promise more things and
eventually you're like running out of
things to promise and you've got to be
bolder and bolder and bolder this is how
you get socialism well-intentioned
liberalism always leads to socialism it
takes years but it happens we're at that
point now okay like the the the the
well-intentioned liberals maybe the the
the smarter you know Democrats that
Republicans have often worked with who I
think always over-promised but know full
well that the Republican colleagues will
sort of measure the the policy and I
don't think they believe it themselves
frankly but they've created a generation
that does believe it this is where we're
at right now the AOC s of the world are
true believers and they've got a lot of
followers this is what happens when this
this lie of compassion gets told too
many times a generation starts to
actually believe it and this is the
situation we're in now this is why 70
percent of the Millennials surveyed will
say they would vote for a socialist now
there's good news and bad news
associated with the number like that
they don't always define socialism
correctly which is good yeah true and
also I was
having a conversation with someone about
this is a day I mean in 1968 how many 20
year olds would have said they would
have voted for socialism it probably
probably 70 percent as well yeah you
know there was a socialist candidate I
can't remember the name right now but I
just saw this quote and it was so
interesting because that socialist
communist candidate back then in the 60s
basically said what I just said you know
you've got a I can't remember the exact
quote but it was something along the
lines of the the the elements of liberal
policy are there to eventually create
the fabric of socialism for us it's like
it's then that is exactly what happens
it happens a little bit at a time and
here's another way of thinking about it
that I help people understand okay so
you want to raise the minimum minimum
wage okay and you want to raise it to 15
bucks an hour or 20 bucks an hour and
that's fine there's it's guaranteed that
you will lose jobs when you do that
that's it's guaranteed okay and so you
lose jobs and depending on how much you
raise it in the cost of living in that
area you'll lose a certain number of
jobs okay
well the the well-intentioned liberal
and government who wants to control the
economy says well we don't want to lose
the jobs okay we'll just make people
hire more just make make the employers
hire more people okay fine so you make
them hire more people but they still
have to pay that minimum wage well their
costs haven't changed and they're their
overall budget hasn't changed so so now
what well then they have to raise prices
right raise prices Jasta cailli well now
there's hyperinflation and that's not
good and also the poor people can't
afford the things that they want to buy
so that's not good
okay well just make them lower the
prices look we're going out of business
okay just take over the business so now
you own the means of production and I'm
not saying it happens that quickly but
that's how it happens like there's
there's there's oh there's a logical
line there well that well-intentioned
first step of intervening in the markets
has consequences and eventually if you
want to control it well you have to
really control it and then you're in a
really bad place because then you're
then you then you're actually
controlling productions when you do that
then you're in a place called Venezuela
yeah
and that isn't turning out so well
all right little tangent right there hi
well it's actually I go into this huge
discussion about the minimum wage in the
book yeah
not because because this actually
relates to mental toughness because the
way I relate it in the book is part of
being part of having fortitude part of
being mentally tough is having the
ability to think through some questions
before you react emotionally very simple
and I'm pretty sure I think I think that
example is used in the chapter called be
still and and I mean that quite
literally just be still when you hear
something that is emotionally triggering
or you disagree with think about that
this notion that there might be another
side to the story like just maybe if you
just ask some questions and at first
again the minimum wage it seems like the
right thing to do like how people should
just get paid more I want them to get
paid more they should so I just give the
arguments in there like there's economic
arguments and there's geographical
arguments by that I mean you know why
would you have a federal minimum wage
that's the same for the entire country
when in San Francisco the the rent is
thirty five hundred dollars a month and
in Lubbock Texas seven hundred dollars a
month you know does that that really
quickly makes the case against a federal
minimum wage not saying that each city
can't do their own thing then I go into
the economic arguments of who's actually
working a minimum wage jobs the point
isn't to make the argument against the
minimum wage the point is to get you to
understand that this issue like many
many other issues and questions has many
many layers to it and if you stop and
you think first assume those layers
exist right
then the next step is look into the
layers and there might be more to it and
when you do that you are exhibiting
mental strength you're exhibiting the
ability to not react but to just ask
questions and like I have a feeling I'm
just a feeling that the the people
really angrily waving those $15 minimum
wage signs have not looked into the our
treatments yeah but they're passionate
yes really um you know I at our factory
up in Maine you know this is a class
thing like sometimes you need more
people to load boxes and who do you get
who do you who do you get to load box
this is an unskilled job like hey we
just need you to move by it's not even
loading by it's moving boxes from here
in the warehouse to where they're gonna
get loaded on trucks to get take shipped
out you know you know who wants that job
a kid that's a 16 years old that you
know does needs gas money and he's gonna
work that job two hours a night whatever
and make a little bit of cash on the
side that's cool we can afford to do
that at that our business the minute you
say hey instead of paying that guy 10
bucks an hour you got to give him $16 an
hour
well now it's guess what we're gonna
take we're gonna just take some of our
other labor and have them fill in you
know half an hour your half an hour
there and all of a sudden with you've
eliminated three jobs that the overall
budget of the business does not change
just because you changed the minimum
wage but there's this like belief and
again you know it's I'm always amazed by
how little pockets put into some of
these you know feel good policy policy
proposals like as if there's no second
third order consequences to these things
and like you just you have to think
through that we just have to that would
be nice
all right let's get back to the book I'm
gonna take you back to the you just did
you just deep reef the entire book we
descend now all right so here we go
awake now in long stool I could not move
I was beaten and for the moment
physically broken
I was riddled with shards and debris
under under the skin and deep within I
was swollen badly suffering from a
thousand small cuts everything burned
and itched though oddly enough I don't
recall any pain in my eyes I said before
that I woke up unable to see but this
was not entirely true I could see I
could not see my surroundings true but I
was certainly seeing I was surrounded by
constant hallucinations the result of my
optic nerve still communicating
erratically with my brain the
hallucinations were lucid and all
followed a pattern I was in Afghanistan
I was with the guys I was in an Afghan
village mud walls and compounds there
was an Afghan man sitting next to me
there were piles of weapons in the
corner I lived my previous experiences I
lived my previous experiences over and
over again I knew it wasn't real I was
hallucinating but not delusional if I
was awake I was seeing these images if I
was lucky enough to fall asleep and
dream never more than 30 minutes then I
would wake up and still wake up still
inside the visual reality of the dream
that sounds insane that was that was
that was insane now was some of that it
was some of that drugs that you were you
on were you on any drugs that were
giving you hallucinations no or this was
just all your optic nerves communicating
and there's there's some I research this
you know later in life and there's
there's some history of this happening
to people who go suddenly blind that
that optic nerve voles continue to do
that it couldn't have been drugs I mean
the only drugs I was on or painkillers
and the wouldn't wouldn't have that
effect there was just some weird things
that was it was it was so weird
and and kind of terrifying and it just
it just it amplified the whole
experience because I knew it wasn't real
I knew it wasn't real there was but I
would I would always see them there and
I would talk about them and so you know
the stranger stories are from my my
friends there's a couple seals who came
to me with Lance to Landstuhl which was
it's such a enormous blessing you know
you can't even describe how important it
is for somebody in that state to just
have somebody they know or at least
somebody they kind of trust it doesn't
even have to be a team guy you know it
could just be somebody who understands
you just there and I remember this old
Afghan man sitting next to me and it was
always like a weird blue light like it
was it was it really was like I'm could
dream out of the movies you know we're
like a band and his face would be kind
of melting I just remembered that very
specifically I don't remember all the
hallucinations but I and I always
remember piles of weapons it was really
like we were I was remembering the
moments which were so many because we
would always do two to three day ops on
that particular deployment
and so we'd holed up in some compound
they knew it you know it's like a you
know are all the guys are just in this
tiny little room together shooting the
[ __ ] and our weapons are kind of strewn
throughout and that's what I would see I
was just seeing that experience all the
time the mud walls and one particularly
weird dream I and I think I do describe
this in the book it's uh I was I was
like I was in a third world country and
like in a department store you know like
going through a very crowded department
store not with people but with clothes
like they're like there did they you
know cuz in like a lot of these
countries they'd just it's not like
Walmart you know where you can
comfortably walk through things like
they pack too much stuff in because they
don't have that much space but they got
a lot of stuff and they pack it in there
and I'm just like trying to move through
these clothes and it's like musty and
the lights are fluorescent like again
like this is just a very thorough bold
country kind of scene you know couldn't
say where it was but I've been to a lot
of third-world countries so my mind is
used to this sort of visualization and
then I woke up and I know I'm awake but
I'm still there that's what really
sucked
to not be able to leave the nightmare
like I was literally living in a
nightmare and we always used the word
literally wrong in our modern-day
society I'm not using it wrong I was
literally living in the nightmare and
like it was inescapable not that's what
sucks because like you just couldn't you
couldn't shake it and that that's all
this was just a horrible place to be it
finally went away when a nurse an astute
nurse an observant nurse just realized
what was going on and she started asking
us about it and my wife is just like
kind of exasperated at this point she
wasn't my wife then but she was you know
fiance then and she's just you know
exhausted and like just trying to deal
with this and I think it was like I
think it was like right after my first
surgery or maybe right before I don't
remember but she was just like how long
has this been going on and we're like
the whole time like ever since I woke up
you know so days and maybe a week I'm
not really sure
um she's like that's not good you should
mean her response was like you will have
a reparable PTSD if this continues you
know because like you just living in a
nightmare is not a great place to be
it's just and and so she shot me up with
a bunch of ativan which was like it's
it's a hard anti-anxiety drug and then
then it got really weird
then the hallucinations chained didn't
go away right away they changed to
Christmas so I was like in a I was like
in like a like a Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer Christmas world this is what
you're seeing yeah even though you can't
see anything this is what you see yeah
it's very Christmas world it's very
vivid it's not like when you close your
eyes and imagine things it's like it was
vivid the Christmas rolled was cool
that's cool yeah it was more relaxing it
was like it was happier um
and then it went black and then black
black was the best that was that was
good it was like you would know you
would never think that you'd be happy to
be blind but like that was that was a
good it was necessary I could finally
take a nap going back to the book here
Tara this is your fiancee at the time
Tara was there when I finally arrived in
Bethesda and never left my side from
that moment on most of my family came up
to see me as did many friends they were
far more worried than I was and their
spirits were low this was most likely
due to the fact that they were mentally
coherent enough to sense the pessimistic
expectations of my surgeons the doctor
did not think I would see again they
said so many times and I simply didn't
believe them my optimism my
self-deception and my belief that the
coming surgery on my left eye would work
and that I would see was nothing less
than a delusional gift that allowed me
to keep my sanity though I am NOT one
for overt expressions of faith I will
say this I genuinely believe God's
strength was working through me then he
was allowing me to believe something
impossible I prayed and my family prayed
and we believed
we believe that the military surgeons
would pick through a pierced and
shrapnel ridden I removed the most
miniscule shards and debris and then
restore my sight we did not have good
reason to believe it but we did it's
interesting that you call this
self-deception and delusional that yeah
it sounds like everyone else was just
like hey man you know losing a good horn
yeah it really stops a obviously that's
exactly right it was it was a necessary
self delusion and again I was like I
don't know why that was it's in that's
why I say Adam could have it had to been
God God saying you know I can't I'm not
gonna save your eye for you bud lorelei
insurgents to do that but I'll at least
allow you to believe that it's possible
because otherwise you're gonna go to
nuts and again it's it's I I think Mike
you know whatever you want to call it
post-traumatic growth afterwards is is a
function of being able to to live
through the experience a certain way
because it's terrifying to think that
you might not see again that's
terrifying and you know and I and I'm
again because that that chapter is
called perspective from darkness there
are other veterans who immediately lost
both eyes they had no chance of seeing
again that's hardship I didn't have to
deal with that you know after somebody
else has had it worse than you always
remember that even when you get blown up
in the face yeah the doctors and that
continued it wasn't just being able to
see anything again it was being able to
see well again I was demanding I was
demanding the first surgery so the first
surgery for my left eye my right eye is
gone my right eye was gone in Kandahar
they happen to be an ophthalmologist
there that enucleated the eye right away
they do that early on so that your body
will focus on the eye that's you know
possibly savable but the right eye was
so screwed up and I wish that pictures
of it and that's kind of gruesome but
you know and people don't want to take
pictures of you in that because they're
like
that's not good to take pictures of you
but but uh you know keep in mind that
the person might want those pictures
later on that it's people don't realize
his kirsty edison and she got you know
she got in the helo crash in afghanistan
and you know she's a beautiful girl and
she had pictures of her face where 50
cal like the way that the helo went down
I mean it it did some massive damage to
her face and she has pictures of it and
look at the pictures and you can't
believe that you know she was able to
recover the way she did it's amazing but
you know she's a marine and I will say
that she's much aligned with your
feelings on this I think she's pretty
stoked that she has those pictures of
herself all jacked totally took those
pictures though was it the kind like Oh
after they got into like the medical you
know what actually I think it was I
think it was if you remember her story
there was some a really good plastic
surgeon like a bright red the ladies
version and female plastic surgeon that
I think was probably like oh I'm gonna
document this yes he's so there's a
difference between that and then like
something like a wait guys and busts up
the phone and start taking [ __ ] like
which is what you think the team guy
would do and I think I would obviously
go all cool check out fans are there I
I'm gonna get some snacks to this and we
got some you know so I've only got one
picture but it's a good week out I mean
it's not it's at least a few days like
it's um there's some healing that has
taken place but I look bad like it looks
like a shock it looks like I'd hit in
the face with a shotgun that's what my
face looks like it's show it to you
right now if you really want to see it
just so you can react to it
I've never posted it because it's a
little it's a little too gruesome for
posting blurry doubt but the option yeah
the well not I kind of lost my train of
thought well yeah so you get that you
get the surgery in the book you talk
about they removed the broken lens yes
oh no copper wire that was in there
right bunch of other debris
so hallucinations stop
and then then your six weeks they got to
put you in a position for six weeks to
recover right so there's a couple things
that happened here that's the picture oh
you know that's about a week after so
there's there's some healing there but
it's not looking great it's yeah that's
rough so damn Yeah right eyes gone left
eye has a as a cataract meaning the lens
which is in the middle of your eye is is
destroyed cataracts are pretty normal
thing for older folks to get you know
just basically means the lens has kind
of I don't know the right term is but
kind of clouds over you need to replace
it in my case it was trauma induced so
just bunch of fragments burst through
the eye and destroyed the lens you can
kind of look at a lens like a window
alright and this is an important way of
thinking about it because if it clouds
over if that windows just you can't see
through it anymore we'll just replace
the windowpane but if the blast destroys
the window then you're trying to so a
new window pane onto basically the
curtains which are like the scelera of
your eye and that was sort of the
situation I was dealing with so the
first miracle was they removed the lens
entirely so okay so that things out
because I remember this I think I think
it was in Landstuhl I sort of remember
them shining a really bright light my
eye just to see if I could see light and
I could see some light when they did
that what I saw was like darkness but
there was like a light almost like we're
in this room right now and there's this
bright light above our heads it's kind
of like that but everything else was
like a cloud like like being like on an
air but like imagine you're like going
through a cumulus cloud as you're taking
off like that's what it looks like very
odd and strange and again so the first
miracle this in a battle you know maybe
a week later when I finally got back to
the Bethesda we did the surgery they
removed the big copper wire that had
really been destroying my eye so that's
good and so we kind of start to see some
blurriness after that you know which is
kind of what I see now as I look at you
now I'm wearing a contact and without if
I took this contact out I wouldn't wreck
nice you I don't know wouldn't know I
wouldn't run into things necessarily but
I can't see anything you know it's it's
it's I mean I well it's like you know
twenty one thousand vision it's I can't
really see anything it's just it's just
blurry can't see clothes can't see far
can't find my glasses if I lose them the
glasses I do have four like that thick
that's what I wear at night or on
airplanes or you know if I don't feel
like wearing a contact so that never
goes away but at the time I wanted it to
go away like I wanted to be like no just
make the eye better doctors why can't
you just do that cuz I got a I got
places to be okay and they're like yeah
do you you know it was like I was like
yeah I mean I was like okay so you just
did this surgery remove the cataract now
I want a new lens so that I don't have
to wear like Contacts and glasses
because I don't look cool in these
glasses right I'm not a fan and uh you
know I don't really have to contact
situation yet and and I actually
wouldn't for two and a half years it
would take to get a really good contact
that's actually comfortable and so I was
like just just do the surgery and
they're like well and I'm they're like
we really shouldn't and I was like okay
what's the how much do we have to wait
to do the surgery you know what's the
what's the minimum time cuz I need to
have it as soon as possible because you
know I got to get back to the platoon
I've got a I've got to go back and
they're like well I mean I guess
technically six weeks I'm like six weeks
it is and like I couldn't see them at
the time but they're looking at each
other like what the hell are you talking
about like this isn't you don't
understand what your situation is it's
like they were just I mean and my wife
tells me all this now cuz I couldn't see
them and I couldn't
I wasn't self-aware enough to gauge
people's reactions I was in you know
totally different state of mind I was on
a lot of painkillers and drugs and so
you know and and and just like full-on
seal mode layer get the job daughter
must get back to platoon kill bad guys
and it's just like wasn't making sense
to people like they were just like I
don't know what's wrong with this guy
and so they just kind of humored me I
think like they're just like yeah sure
and we'll definitely definitely do that
but they would have no and no intention
of doing it for good reason and then and
then what you're talking about the six
weeks blindness that occurred later
so at least miracles happened and like
we saved my eye and that was really
exciting but then they you know but
they're but they're looking at it every
day and they do this one test and they
see this hole in my retina so that's not
a big deal because it's just just a hole
you know it means there's some blind
spots and as I look at you I can kind of
see the blind spot it's like right in my
face an own but I deal with it it's
annoying when I read frankly the problem
with that is your retina the anatomy of
your retina causes that hole to expand
there's a film there's like a it's like
a membrane on the back of your retina
that creates tension and so anytime
there's a hole in your retina that means
the hole will just expand slowly so it's
macular degeneration this again this
happens with older folks quite a bit the
way to fix that is remove the membrane
we're not really sure why the membranes
on there in the first place and so you
just remove the membrane and then you're
good all right but and that's fine
that's actually pretty normal surgery
but for me it was a really high-risk
surgery because you know my eyes so
fragile and so they're worried about the
retina detaching luckily it did not you
know because well who knows why again
God's intervention and but you do have
to be face down for six weeks to recover
from that so that was just just suck you
had to lay face down the entire time for
six you have the latest face down
because what they do is they they inject
this gas into your eye and that creates
a bubble which creates tension so and if
the bubble is meant to be pressed up
against your retina to keep it in place
the only way for it to press up against
your retina is for you to be looking
down and so you just look just sucks
you just have to be face down doesn't
matter how you're doing it just lay down
or walk facedown or whatever it is but
just make sure you're facing down for
six weeks and you're blind the whole
time
most of the time they'll do this like
one eye at a time so if somebody can see
still but you know I'm not a one eye at
a time kind of guy anymore
you get past that you say when the six
weeks were over I sat up and I was not
blind moreover with the help of a truly
remarkable contact lens from Boston
sight to which the Navy referred me
years later I was eventually returned to
20/20 correct hole vision in my left eye
that's the story of being blown up I
can't say I recommend the experience yet
even as it was happening even in the
moment after the blast I had to admit it
could have been worse I still had my
legs I had my arms I had ten fingers and
ten toes my brain worked even after a
severe concussion I was still alive it
is impossible not to constantly think of
the many veterans who have sacrificed so
much more impossible not to think of
Seale Petty Officer second class
Mike Mansoor who threw himself on a
grenade while on a rooftop in Ramadi in
Iraq 2006 saving his teammates
impossible not to think of Air Force
Master Sergeant John Chapman who fought
all night against the Taliban coming in
and out of consciousness from his wounds
eventually succumbing to them on that
Afghan Ridgeline but only after earning
the Medal of Honor for saving 23
servicemembers impossible not to think
of my platoon members and dear friends
Dave warson and Pat fix who were killed
just two months after I was evacuated
from Helmand impossible not to think of
their loved ones who had been expecting
them home a month later impossible not
to think of the eight men whose initials
are tattooed on my chest in remembrance
Charles Keating the fourth Patrick fix
Dave warson Brad Kavner
Brett Mary you Kevin Evert Brendan
Looney and Tom Falc
this is the simple reality others have
had it harder than me many many others
from that darkness comes realism from
that realism comes gratitude from
gratitude comes perspective a healthy
sense of perspective is an antidote to
outrage is an antidote to self-pity
despair and weakness it's not a cure-all
for your mental state when faced with
adversity but it is sure to dull the
edges of your worst tendencies toward
mental breakdown yeah that's the that's
the perspective that you and I already
talked about today that perspective that
it would be seemed like it would be very
helpful for people to think about it is
and you know I'm using extreme examples
right not everybody can relate to that
but they don't have to and I don't I
don't want you to go be in a terrible
situation just to earn some perspective
right like but just the simple reminder
to yourself that it exists like somebody
else has had it harder that's there's a
comfort in that I think and it is an
antidote to self-pity self-pity is a
gateway to the outrage culture that I
think we see all around us and so that
is a gateway to the socialistic
tendencies I think that we've been
seeing as of late and you can avoid
these things with some perspective and
gratitude and you know it's it's again
it's it's hard for anybody the teams to
ever feel sorry for themselves when you
know because you know of these guys and
you know some of those guys I listed of
course
and you know if there's ever a reason
you need to get up in the morning not at
4:30 but like like later you know get a
normal human time then then the boys who
wish they could get up you know that's a
good reason because they would like to
be able to get up and they can't and
their widows are really wishing they
would get up too and they can't you know
and the Manus where I mentioned unsung
heroes but the widows are here the the
heroes of the SEAL Teams III have yet to
meet the wife of one of those guys who
fell into self-pity and despair I have
only met I only know ones who have
overcome with the greatest grace it's
just amazing I've watched these watch
these women just serve as the most
ultimate example mothers as well you
know that I know you know like Debbie
Lee for instance it's absolutely it's
just it's just incredible to watch that
fortitude we just we just couldn't do it
without them yeah it's always one of the
things about about marks mom and life
and I talk about this a lot is you know
when when we called her from Iraq to
talk to her and to console her she was
consoling us you know she was wanted to
make sure we were okay she wanted to
make sure we were handling think she
wanted to know if we needed anything you
know that was her attitude out of the
gate now and that shows you you know the
kind of people that you're talking about
you know someone that's that's taking
their own personal worst nightmare that
any you know any parent could ever have
of losing their kid and immediately
saying well what can I do for you guys
yeah it is unbelievable
he's uh you know it was recent friend
good friend I lost was was Chuck Keating
the fourth and you know his his wife
started a foundation in his name
his dad as well and his family's just
been incredible but that's not that
that's that's not the exception like
that's been the rule from what I've seen
and it's so much harder to be the family
left behind than it is to to be us I
think you know we go and we choose to do
this thing overseas and we're doing it
with our brothers in arms and we love it
and we know what's coming the next day
we we're in control to an extent to the
greatest extent we can be but our family
is not there they're their life doesn't
change except that we're just not there
and they don't know what's happening and
then they get a call and I don't
actually go into detail and my wife's
experience on the perspectives from
darkness but but you know she gets a
call and so her only consolation is that
it's a call and not a guy at the door
but you know it's a call that she's
getting before 6 a.m. and before she her
alarm goes off to go to work and and
then there's you know the very typical
kind of lack of exact information given
to her she's not sure what my face looks
like because they're because they don't
know what my face looks like they're not
sure if it's still there but my head is
still there like there's all this
misinformation get enough enough
information to just plant seeds of
absolute horror it's horrible and guess
who but but you know who the who you
know who went there first was the loony
family row you know it's like it's it's
it was it's Amy Looney their canoe her
husband two years earlier and she's the
one there consoling Tara and it's just
that that's the type of community that
the SEAL Teams is blessed with and you
know it's it is it is a true blessing
and it's unique I wish
were broader I wish we could say you
know I talked to other friends and other
and other communities that it doesn't
seem it's not as good and I wish it was
I wish we should all strive to just to
take care of each other in that way so
rolling into your next chapter and I
haven't made my caveat that I always
make I'm not reading this whole book
right now and so when it skips around
it's because I'm not reading the whole
book you have to buy the book so that
you can hear the whole thing and and
then we're just you know you and I are
going off of a bunch of tangents and
which is awesome but you know the book
that has so many great details in it and
the stories are so clear and they're
real personal too so you got to buy the
book to get that got to buy the book you
gotta buy the book so the next chapter
which you mentioned earlier is called
who's your hero and I'm gonna jump to
this part right here where you talking
about the SEAL Teams it says the SEAL
Teams like any like many military units
are relentless in the pursuit of
establishing hero archetypes doing so is
extremely important when the goal is to
create a monoculture
that operates as a mission oriented team
this is a community with a very deep
sense of who we want to be we talk about
it all the time and we beat it into our
trainees Jocko specifically into our
trainees I did some here's some of the
things that will be beaten into you you
will be someone who is never late you
will be someone who takes care of his
men gets to know them and puts their
needs before yours you will be someone
who does not quit in the face of
adversity
you will be someone who takes charge and
leans when no one else will you will be
detail-oriented always vigilant you will
be aggressive in your actions but never
lose your cool you will have a sense of
humor because sometimes that is all that
can get you through the darkest hours
you will work hard and perform even when
no one is watching you will be creative
and think outside the box even if it
gets you in trouble you are a rebel but
not a mutineer you are a jack of all
trades and master of none and then you
go into the official ethos which you
mentioned earlier
I was debating if I should read this and
I think I'm actually just gonna read it
it's a good ethos so here we go in times
of war or uncertainty there's a special
breed of warrior ready to answer our
nation's call a common man with uncommon
desire to succeed forged by adversity he
stands alongside America's finest
special operations forces to serve his
country the American people and protect
their way of life I am that man my
Trident is a symbol of honor and
heritage bestowed upon me by the heroes
that have gone before it embodies the
trust of those I have sworn to protect
by wearing the Trident I accept the
responsibility of my chosen profession
and way of life it is a privilege that I
must earn every day my loyalty to
country and team is beyond reproach I
humbly serve as a guardian to my fellow
Americans always ready to defend those
who are unable to defend themselves
I do not advertise the nature of my work
nor seek recognition for my actions I
voluntarily accept the inherent hazards
of my profession placing the welfare and
security of others before my own I serve
with honor on and off the battlefield
the ability to control my emotions and
my actions regardless of circumstance
sets me apart from other men
uncompromising integrity is my standard
my character and honor are steadfast my
word is my bond
we expect to be we expect to lead and be
led in the absence of orders I will take
charge lead my teammates and accomplish
the mission I lead by example in all
situations I will never quit
I persevere and thrive on adversity my
nation expects me to be physically
harder and mentally stronger than my
enemies
if knocked down I will get back up every
time I will draw on every remaining
ounce of strength to protect my
teammates and to accomplish our mission
I am never out of the fight
we demand discipline we expect
innovation the lives of my teammates and
the success of our mission depend on me
my technical skill tactical proficiency
and attention to detail my training is
never complete we train for war and
fight to win I stand ready to bring the
full spectrum of combat power to bear in
order to achieve my mission and the
goals established by my country the
execution of my duties will be swift and
violent when required
yet guided by the very principles that I
served to defend brave men have fought
and died building the proud tradition
and feared reputation that I am bound to
uphold in the worst of conditions the
legacy of my teammates steadies my
resolve and silently guides my every
deed I will not fail
so that's the seal ethos and
interestingly or if you know where that
came from
no I was actually I just thought about
that in last three seconds so I was like
I would love to be a fly on the wall as
this was getting drafted so it was
written in 2005 a bunch of us went to
San Clemente Island I would say there
was maybe 10 or 15
yeah probably 10 or 15 teen guys that
went out to San Clemente Island and made
this and made the the other like shorter
one the little the little short SEAL
ethos and it was actually part of what
was driving it was in response to before
I think was before with what year did
you get to the teams started buds in
2006 yeah okay so in like 2003 2004
there was a platoon that just there was
a platoon commander that dyed his hair
he was overseas on deployment dyed his
hair blonde had a pierced earring and
was selling drugs to his platoon I mean
just a total disaster and then there was
a bunch of other you know look as you
know as we know like we're in the news a
lot and there's spikes were one of their
news for some negative things and so
there was a couple other really negative
things that was kind of the peak was
this guy dealing drugs inside of his own
platoon and the platoon being a total
disaster and getting disbanded and sent
home from deployment
by the way this is like during a time of
war so you know the admiral who you know
was a great guy said look we need to do
something about this and that's what so
we went out and the and this is what
came out of it I'm looking at I still
remember some little things like there
were some things where I was you know a
little bit more a woman I wanted them to
be a little bit more aggressive on some
things like yeah I remember
I remember I got shut down one of the
lines that I was like no it should be
destroy your enemy like that's what we
do and it didn't make the cut I think it
was in I think it was this part right
here where it says I stand I stand - I
stand ready to bring the full spectrum
of combat power to bear in order to
achieve my mission and the goals
established by my country my version it
was to achieve my mission and destroy my
enemy or destroy the enemies of our
country something like that and I got I
got the reins pulled in on me there was
there was quite a few but you know I did
all right I mean we got some discipline
in there right we did pretty good I love
to see what the chaco version would be
yeah you wanted to go more aggressive no
way impossible to believe you know and
it's interesting and one of the reasons
that like a lot of the discussion around
it and there were some grand there was a
bunch of great guys out there I mean it
was like the Admiral picked guys to go
out there was pretty awesome
a great crew of people and at the time
you know it was 2005 like we didn't
really have as much combat experiences
we have you know now which is just
awesome but my attitude was like listen
we're not writing this 405's right we're
not writing this for SEAL team
commanders or Commodores like this thing
should be leveled at the point of aim
point of impact should be an e5 team
guys look I know that this guy that was
a was an officer that had this bad
platoon but like that's that's who not
who were named it we should not have
those problems and like that's yes we
got to handle that but this should be
aim point of aim point of impact should
be an e5 team guy that's that's needs to
understand the ethos and go hey I need
to do the right thing because by the way
if you're in a platoon and you've got
squared away he fives they'll destroy
that they'll they'll crush that officer
that's doing dumb things yeah they'll
kill him not kill him literally Vietnam
frag style but they will get him removed
you know and you know that's what will
happen so yeah and I think it hits that
pretty well yeah yeah it does pretty
good it does pretty good yeah it's a
great ethos and it was awesome to be out
there when this thing was getting
written
and then see it you know I it it's
always interesting to be a part of
things like that that you don't really
know like I mean you don't run it really
understand what you're doing at the time
you know you're just trying to get the
job done you're trying to do a good job
but you don't always know what the
impacts gonna be later when you when you
do something like that but yeah it's an
honor to be out there and make that
happen or help make that happen again
there's a bunch of people out there I
was I may very well but know that I
wouldn't I won't say was the junior guy
but there because there was you know
there was a bunch of Master Chief's out
there a bunch of badass Master Chief's
here so yeah it's cool and it's just
it's so important and I'm gonna stop
jumping ahead on the book now that I
understand what we're doing because I've
already yeah I already hit this part
pre-brief to you I guess yeah but the
it's so important for an organization to
understand who they want to be and that
was the whole reason I put the seal
ethos in there because there's a deep
cultural mindset that is beaten into us
you know quite literally there's the
more high-minded philosophical approach
which is the seal ethos but it does a
good job of relating to the the lowest
level guy to but it's it's it goes way
beyond the steel ethos I mean there's so
many other lessons that get repeated
like mantras throughout training
throughout but it's about who you are
like what it means to be a guy who wears
the Trident like what that really means
and this is simple stuff you know and I
listed some of it earlier right left
just don't quit just be on time like
work when no one's watching you know
it's like just really simple stuff but
it's like it's who you better be and you
better be funny okay that's actually
part of our culture harder to be a
better to you guys you better have a
really sick sense of humor
and like you better go after each other
but it better be funny yeah you know
it's gotta actually and like we rely on
that dark humor in a really fundamental
way that I think it's maybe maybe a side
of us that isn't as prevalent in all the
books and all the movies but like I like
to think we're pretty damn funny I mean
I've been on Saturday Night Live so
obviously I'm funny yeah
you know yeah I know a thick skin and
you know the ability to verbally spar
with people 24 hours a day from the
moment you report in to work the moment
you show up until and any mistake that
you make you better you know you you
throw a shot on a you know while you're
shooting you throw a shot and hit
something that you shouldn't hit or
whatever it's you just sign up for
ridicule because that's what's about to
happen the greatest thing it really is
you got a bunch of stuff in here that's
you start talking about traits and you
know again it's what's what you're
talking about some of the traits of you
must be someone that can take a joke
it's very simple you want to be
productive you want to be someone that
makes progress every single day you want
to be someone who identifies a goal and
sticks with it again you know what I
like about these is just going back to
the earlier conversations if you think
about how you would want your kid to act
these are good things this is how you
want your kid act you want to be you
want to be seen as reliable you want
people to ask things of you because you
have a reputation for getting it done
reliability is an element of force that
you want to be you want to have the
ability to delay gratification a
mentally tough person can avoid the next
cupcake and save it for later after
earning with some exercise you want to
be even-tempered you don't ever want to
lose it emotions don't drive your
actions you want to be humble you have
confidence but not overbearing you want
to be someone that internalizes someone
else's point of view before speaking at
them like these are the kind of things
you're talking about and and you you you
put you say this the question is how do
we become the heroes we want to be my
answer sanctioned intellectual property
theft
that's how no one has a patent on good
habits you can steal them identify your
heroes and emulate the character traits
that make that person more successful
than you currently are and this and this
gets into this I love this this is one
of my favorite chapters to write because
I love psychology you know Jordan
Peterson's one of my favorite thinkers
out there there's a lot of psychological
references in this chapter and
and then another one too but especially
this one and hero archetypes and we
already already hit what I meant by hero
archetypes and that and I just think
that's so important you have to have a
visualization of what you're looking up
to you have to look at yourself in 10
years and think okay that's that's how
how would that person react to this
situation I should react that way now
like you know and it's hard and this
isn't supposed to be easy
and when I say sanctioned intellectual
property theft it's like look at the
attributes of people you respect you
know like what are they doing like if
you want to get to where they're at just
copy them this isn't this isn't rocket
science you know if this is an anyone
any of your listeners are like well yeah
that's why I listen to Jack oh you know
yeah who isn't and you and I were
talking about this earlier this idea of
sanctioned intellectual property theft
you know extreme ownership is this his
personal response did I did I did I make
up personal responsibility in the form
of extreme ownership no I didn't I
didn't make up the you know discipline
equals freedom I did am I the first
person that ever said you know what if
you have discipline in your life you'll
have more freedom I mean it's in the
Bible like these aren't things that I
old ideas of the best exactly and you
know maybe I worded it in a way that was
easier for people to understand or came
at it from a different angle or whatever
but the fact of the matter is this
stuff's out there and these are these
these traits that you're talking about
are just as you were saying earlier it's
like oh we want your kid to not lose
their temper that that's what you want
your kid to be reliable these are really
basic things and yet if you don't
identify them which is your point if you
don't identify them and you know that's
what in the warrior kid book so I
written these kids books well one of the
things in the warrior kid books is first
his uncle who's a seal teaches him all
the different codes mmm all the
different warrior codes from from
ancient times till today to the ranger
coat to the seal coat they're in the
book and then he says you need to write
your own code and that's what he does in
the book right says
code of what it means to be a warrior
kid and that's what he lives up to so
same thing you're saying here yeah it's
in and then again to the discussion
about hierarchies and why that's kind of
an important way of looking at this
because it and also why I said you don't
pick a person to be your hero you pick
many real or imagined characters who who
excel in a certain hierarchy and that
that's an important thing to define
there's different types of hierarchies
like some people excel in a jiu jitsu
hierarchy if you want to be good at jiu
jitsu
copy this person okay but you don't
listen to everything they say because
they might be all screwed up in some
other way this is right this is it this
is a fact yeah but but like you know
follow this leader like there's
something about that leader that I like
and that there's something that makes me
want to follow them what is it I should
identify it I can start to emulate those
behaviors one note I made in in in your
book here is uh when you said when you
said to do that I have plus bad examples
and in my latest book leadership
strategy tactics I had this beautiful
situation unfolding where I had a
horrible officer that we had a mutiny
and got him fired and then the guy that
took over was the best guy ever and
super humble gave us ownership I mean he
was just awesome
but I learned probably as much from the
egotistical guy and seeing how we all
reacted to him and seeing how we didn't
want to listen to him we didn't want to
follow as I learned from the guy that
was a just fantastic leader sure so I
look at you know hey here's here's I was
always pulling the good things from
people but then also looking at people
with negative examples and saying okay I
know not to act like that
the villains yeah that heroes you got to
have villains and it's um and and I
guess the point of that chapter is is
yeah to remind people of what some of
the good attributes are and and to then
to cut and to think consciously about
identifying those attributes identifying
yourself as the hero you want to be and
then living up to that so that's that's
part of it but and but the broader
cultural conversation is the fact that
outrage culture is
this product of the fact that we have we
have started to looked at the wrong hero
archetypes we have started to elevate
attributes that are not heroic at all
into a heroic reality and and it's it's
not good and it's sort of that's the
second part of the chapter the wrong
heroes and it's it's it's what we talked
about this aggrieved victim status the
the loudest person on the internet the
snarky astone on the Internet the one
owning the libs or the cons you know
it's like that one gets the most likes
like it's its passion over
sophistication and these are not good
things I understand that it's
entertaining right I understand the
temptation especially on social media
but it's really detrimental to our
larger conversation you know why should
the fists banging activists you know you
know speaking truth to power whatever
the hell that means why should that be
the person we listen to just because
they're mad like why why does anger
beget some kind of credibility it
doesn't make any sense but that's how
we're acting as a culture it doesn't
make any sense though and like I just
want us to think through that I guess
the whole point of the chapter and we'd
be better off if we started to kind of
rediscover the heroes that have gotten
us through thousands of years of
civilization and again the oldest ideas
are the best ones if people have been
talking about certain heroic attributes
for thousands of years there's really
good chance those are good ideas because
they've lasted and they've gone through
trial and error but but like every
generation you know you got it fun when
you have to teach those they deals and
and then as a young person you have to
stop and think maybe there's a reason
it's like this maybe I'm not the first
one to think in revolutionary terms you
know like just maybe okay there's a
reason your granddad is telling you it's
this way and it's not because he's just
stupid and out of touch like just stop
and like let's think about that as a
possibility
yeah there's it's weird with this I
would love to try and trace back the
roots of this because one thing I don't
want one time we were on this podcast we
were talking about something and
somebody asked a question on a key
and I basically what I said was and I
think you turned it into a clip echo
Charles as I was saying like hey you
gotta stifle those emotions but don't
let those emotions out what are you
kidding me like you can't let that show
and the reaction from some people was
you know that's horrible
you should never stifle your emotions
they'll that'll you be turns into these
whatever the mental problems and all
this stuff and I'm like people took what
I said to the extreme which clearly I
don't really believe in anything extreme
that's why I wrote the book dichotomy of
leadership right extreme ownership yeah
yeah yeah well well interestingly you
know extreme ownership can be taken too
far and you can have people in
leadership positions that go to an
extent where they want to own everything
and they don't decentralize so that's
why we wrote the dichotomy of leadership
because you have to find balance in
everything so with this idea of stifle
your emotions look oh if you lose a
loved one I'm not saying you need to
write off the whole time right no and
also as a leader in any position if
you're walking around completely stoic
with no emotions you won't attack you
won't you won't you won't connect with
anybody and so you don't have any
personal connections with anybody that's
not a seal platoon if you're in a seal
platoon and you have no personal
connection with your guys and your
platoon you're not a leader if they
don't respect you they won't follow you
and I've seen that kind of leader yeah
absolutely doesn't work it doesn't work
so when I say stifle your emotions I'm
talking about your little petty emotions
that your guests spawn up about
something yeah that's what I'm talking
about
and you know and especially in my
business and like politics it's like you
realize quickly you've got to define
what you mean in very clear terms
because everybody's first reaction is to
totally take it out of context or or
just assume the worst of what you meant
assume the worst of intentions I go into
the great amount of detail about this in
the book too because that that's that's
a that's a big marker of outrage
cultures this does need this like desire
to be like just assume the worst of what
you meant Oh
stifle my emotions oh okay just walk
around like robots of course that's not
what you meant
you know like let's let's be gracious
with how we understand each other just
like just a just a tad would be a lot
better off next chapter it's called no
plan B which is you know got a little
counterintuitive sound to it because as
a seal and as a human being you're
always like oh you know gotta have a
plan B in case something goes wrong
here's your premise behind behind this
you don't entertain the plan B option
because when you do your entertaining
failure and in entertaining failure you
will embrace it ultimately the no plan B
mentality isn't about keeping you from
doing something rather it's about
embracing a positive goal as your only
choice it's about enabling you to do
something it's about clearing the path
to your goals to your achievements to
your tasks and your responsibilities
so you're explain your idea behind no no
Plan B so this this started out as I was
thinking about how not to quit at Budds
and and whenever any time I'd ever been
asked that question I would simply say
well because I never had a choice
because I just didn't think about buds
as a choice I didn't think about it as
an achievement that I would you know
hopefully make it was just like okay I
just have to do this because that's just
I just have to you know and like and I
think most of us who made it through
buds yeah just had that mentality like
okay just I just have to do another boat
race and man this really sucks
like I really hate this but I just I
just I don't have a choice you know like
it's there's no other option there's
something liberating about that
mentality it's the only mentality you
can have and it is truly a no plan B
mentality so and I'm very Anna and I
explained that in the book I'm like I
don't mean no contingencies obviously
you have to plan ahead but no plan B is
fundamentally about not quitting and not
quitting needs to be defined rather
carefully you know and i and i point out
like changing directions in life could
seem like quitting it's not necessarily
like you're not a good artist
just stop it's just not good it's time
to change directions man you know and
that's okay like that's that's okay that
doesn't like you know it's and then I go
into much deeper converse
about living with purpose ultimately
what I mean by living your plan a and
not living your Plan B it is about
living with purpose and purpose is
something only you can tell really if
you're living up to it or not it's hard
to tell from the outside but you know
you know if you quit like you know if
you just didn't do the right thing to
live up to your end goal and and and and
execute the millions of smaller tasks
that you need to execute to live up to
your end goal and I think this is also
the chapter where I really go into some
deeper discussions about one of my
favorite quotes from Saint John Paul or
Pope John Paul the second which is in
America freedom is is it's not the right
to do what you want but to but to what
the freedom to do what you ought or I'm
screwing up that quote a little bit but
the point is this you live with ordered
Liberty ordered Liberty means we live
with a purpose we have with freedom and
with that freedom we have a
responsibility to live as we ought to
live and then we have to define okay
what is living how we ought to live like
that's a whole other discussion this is
why religion is so important this is why
religion is such an important foundation
our judeo-christian history is a very
important foundation of our culture even
if you don't believe in God you have to
admit that we get our morality from this
place from the Ten Commandments and that
matters like it matters in a really deep
way and I'm a Rhino are kind of that
sense of absolute morality and where our
laws come from and where this is where
this notion comes from of what it is to
do the right thing like how do you
define the right thing again we've
already talked about this if it's based
on thousands of years of wisdom and
trial and error there's a good chance
that it's right okay not a guaranteed
chance but there's a really good chance
even if it doesn't feel good or doesn't
feel nice and compassionate it's real
and it creates a sustainable Society and
ultimately sustainable societies are
should be our end goal now I'll check
out rage culture is is counter to a
sustainable
xiety it is it is chaos manifested in
our our words and our actions
yeah the you say here pure freedom is
chaos anarchy and moral decay freedom to
do what you like without any moral
compass can quickly result in the
temptation to indulge in habits that may
feel good momentarily but are wholly
detrimental to yourself and others pure
freedom detached from a higher sense of
purpose results in at best in
overindulgence lack of discipline
unfaithful relationships and some drug
use at worst they can result in the
total deterioration of a society and and
you know this is I think it was actually
Jason Gardner went before he was out of
the teams but he he was listening to
podcast he was you hear me talk about I
think he's heard me talk about the
gulags or or just something and he goes
hey discipline equals freedom that
applies to societies - doesn't it I'm
like yes it does if you have total
freedom everyone do it whichever you
want well then you you you're destroyed
and you end up a slave - well you end up
a slave to any number of things whereas
if you have discipline inside of a
society which is called law and order
and you follow those rules well then you
actually end up with more freedom which
is what we try to do here in discipline
equals freedom is the simplest way of
putting that because it's it's very true
and if it's been true for a very long
time it's indeed indeed a next chapter
again I'm jumping forward to your next
chapter this is the Challenger if we've
got to read the book yeah they want more
absolutely a lot more in there there's
there's a ton and you know you do I you
you give a lot of almost academic level
back up so you give some like common
sense stuff you give some academic can
you talk about the psychology psychology
cool viewpoint of things some historical
references you do a great job of
balancing out what you're saying and
showing multiple examples from different
aspects so that's why there's that's why
the book you have to read the book to
get all that information the next one is
called be still I got to read this
little section in the SEAL Teams
our first exercise in training the mind
to be still is drown proofing and yes it
is it is ridiculous as it sounds as
legend has it and it may indeed just be
legend drown proofing originates from
the story of an American POWs Vietnam as
the Vietcong transported him along the
Mekong River they decided they'd have
enough had enough of him and threw him
overboard but this was not some
magnanimous gesture of human civility he
was not being released for good behavior
they expected him to drown it was
reasonable expectation his hands were
tied behind his back and his feet were
tied together visualize that for a for a
second
this creates quite the predicament
especially when you are trying not to
drown he had to figure out how to swim
to shore and as the story goes he did
just that ever since then a key element
of seal training involves drown proofing
us making sure that we too can jump from
a boat with our hands and feet tied and
then you go over the multiple ways to do
this and you say here to do this it
requires that you do not panic
while instructors are yelling don't
panic and and that's you know you talked
about that as being sort of one of your
first lessons and learning how to be
calm and not freak out about stuff it's
it's it's such a necessary part of
military training and drown proofing is
an excellent way to do it not not
because we actually think that might
happen like how I'm lucky would that be
that'd be unlucky or lucky and it's like
wow okay you like is just like training
you know they put a weight on you though
you're screwed or you know there's a lot
of ways to tie you up anyway I'm not the
point the point is not that you're
preparing for this specific
eventualities
the point is is that you you have a set
of skills and you better implement those
skills while the fear of drowning is all
around you and of course it gets worse
than the drown proofing gets into dive
comp or pool compco which is my it's
probably my least favorite thing in buds
when I got to buds I had no idea what it
was they had a Texas Chainsaw Massacre
movie poster up but it had
it was crossed out and said buds pool
caught Massacre and they had like drown
a regulator on a person getting murdered
by Leatherface yes yeah so I was like
well I wonder what that is but yeah sure
enough sounds great yeah sign me up you
know uh I think like yeah I felt poke on
my first my first go at pool cop I
failed and I was recycled to the next
class no I mean I know how we I got to
retest again on Monday so I'm cool comp
on Friday
yeah and we got retested on Monday if we
failed I failed okay well yeah I mean I
feel first very rarely very really
through the first time yeah I was not
happy
what's welcome pool comp is they put an
old-school dive rig on you so like the
old-school scuba tanks and this thing
called the what's it called a dual hose
regulator I think there's a hose that
comes in that brings the air and there's
one that you blow out and they put you
down on the bottom of the pool and they
just start to just mess with you they
rip your regulator or the rip your mask
off and then they start tying knots in
your regulator that you have to then
untie underwater and you have to follow
all these proper procedures to get
everything back on meanwhile they're
slapping you in the head they're
grinding your face into the thing into
the pool deck and it's it sucks and
eventually they tie something called a
whammy knot which is a knot that you
can't get out and so they tie this
whammy knot and then you have to go the
proper ditching procedures which means
you take your rig completely off you try
you have to attempt to get it to work if
you can't get it to work
you take off your weight belt you lay it
over your rig and then you look at your
instructor you give them the thumbs up
and then you do a proper free swim or
ascent and if you mess up any of you and
there's procedures for everything if you
mess them up then you fail so but it's
it dude it's it's it's no joke like they
come out and freaking hammer you yeah
and they always they always get you as
you have exhaled so yeah they're
watching the bubbles wave in the way
they've called a surf hit mmm like so
they're simulating this wave this
amazingly complex wave that somehow ties
your hoses and
it's like isn't true that's not real
okay like there's no wave like that but
it's not the point you know it's it's
same with drown proofing that the point
is not to prepare you for this
eventualities there is no way in hell
that your hoses will ever be tied in
knots
mostly because you'll never use a rig
like this that actually can be tied in
knots because this rig is not it's it's
just for training so that's not the
point into the point is the procedures
the point is you're drowning
will you still calm yourself and work
through procedures that's the entire
point of the exercise if you panic you
are going to fail and there's
physiological reasons for that because
you're using more objects freaking out
and there's psychological reasons and
they're just the instructor these
instructors are seals they don't want a
guy in the teams that's gonna be on a
dive with them that's gonna freak out if
something goes wrong because stuff goes
wrong when you're diving yeah so that
that T you know from your perspective
was a was a the initial recognition of
like hey I better be calm right be still
as you say and yeah the reason I say be
still because I was thinking of the
patrolling acronym that we use locals
yep no stop look listen smell mm-hmm and
that's that's exactly what it sounds
like you stop because you've you've
you've done something to in the
environment maybe you landed with a
helicopter and that's actually you know
I don't want to give too much away in
the book but there's a really great
intro to this chapter everybody you got
to buy it and know what it is and so you
stop and you you you've created a
disturbance so stop and look around just
chill and look around and then keep
moving
that's sills sills we just that's what
we say and as a patrolling tactic it
also kind of sounds like still and it's
kind of the same meaning same oh yeah
for sure
that's why I named the chapter be still
there and and then you apply that to
your life because I I understand that
not everybody is going to be thrown
overboard with their hands and feet tied
but if you are I go in a great detail
about how to overcome that particular
predicament it is yeah there's a lot of
methodology there it's much easier than
you think as long as you don't panic so
and uh it'll this is another chapter
called do something hard so hey you know
what you do something art could be drown
proofing and everybody can do this do it
with a buddy though we're not sure
that's the worst thing one up one down
luckily it's hard to tie your own hands
behind your back without a buddy so the
the point is this it's again old lessons
count to 10 before you react but that's
fundamentally what this chapters about
and we have a had a habit lately given
the given the extreme nature of our kind
of immediate gratification that occurs
with social media to react very quickly
and wildly about things our media reacts
unbelievably quickly and wildly about
things and it is it is a disservice to
our country it is I mean I that's an
extreme statement but it is true and has
gotten out of hand and it's it's so bad
that I felt the need to write this book
our media does it but we're but again
their media is feeding off of us we have
to do better as individuals we have to
to say like that's not going to work on
me you know that extent that that quick
over-the-top reaction is not going to
work on me I'm not gonna do it I'm not
gonna feed into it I'm not gonna reward
it that's that's our duty you have to
not click on clickbait headlines yeah
well I mean I can't help myself I'm
gonna click on the click but I'm not
gonna react to it right yeah you know it
even for good practice go ahead and
click on it see if it makes you mad and
if it does do it again it's incredible
when you click on a click same article
and I'm talking mainstream news media
and you go oh my gosh I can't believe
that happened and you click on it you're
like wait a sec yeah that's not what
happened
I just got click baited don't let it
happen and the problem is actually the
problem is is that people don't click
the problem is oh they're just really
yeah and I go into the flooded detail on
that actually I give some example I
could give examples every single day I
just kind of chose some random ones for
the book but an example might be the
examples I use in the book are regarding
something like environmental regulations
because this is a very motion
topic for people when you hear the Trump
administration repealed 12 Obama era
environmental regulations here's what
you're thinking and be honest this is
what you're thinking you're thinking
black Gore Green sludge losing into a
river you're thinking black smoke like
emanating from a factory all of a sudden
while you know these corporate fat cats
count their money and birds are falling
out of the sky like this is what you're
thinking if you're being like this is
the visualization that occurs but is it
true nobody asks the second question is
it true yeah what does this actually
mean or what does it mean or like why
would they deregulate that you know what
why was it put in place just a few years
ago you know I mean what kind of
regulation was it you know is there a
good reason for and then I go into
basically a case study on something
called new source regulation and we
don't have to talk about it now but it's
it's I basically write a case study on
this because it's important like there's
there's there's good examples and
there's and there's the there's in the
headline about that particular
regulation basically said you know Trump
is removing air pollution regulations so
again your mind goes to those places I
just talked about the article itself
kind of gives both sides like actually
not a bad article and this is usually
the case and my experience because I you
know do this every day and my experience
the the writer the journalist is not
always but a lot of times like actually
kind of gives a balanced article but the
editorialized headline is terrible
totally misleading you know that their
own article debunks the headline and
you're like what the hell is going on
here okay
now a lot of that's oftentimes because
the journalist is not the one writing
the header okay so that's it's a whole
different story and then you look into
it right and it's like okay well it
turns out yeah they want to they want to
make it easier for factories to to
update their systems or power generation
plans to update their systems they don't
want to have them go through this new
source review regulation which is
extremely costly and unpredictable and
environmentalists say well that's just
Kadesh you're just given giving away to
corporations right you're deregulating
them but it's like well no as it turns
out if you want to put a carbon capture
addition to your power plant which means
capturing more pollutants or carbon
dioxide then you can you have to go
through this extremely costly new source
review well maybe we should stop that
you know thinking that's and that's the
background you know any I go to can go
to a lot more detail on that but just
one example I can think of an example
almost every single day like the
headline just isn't what you think
you know let's let's let's bring it back
to coronavirus so the headline is you
know the Trump administration screwed up
the coronavirus tests like South Korea
is testing 20,000 people a day and we've
only done like you know 10,000 tests or
something and by the time you're
listening to this podcast that reality
has changed drastically but in our
current moment that's what happened in
the last couple months and there's some
truth to that like the America was
behind on tests but who's actually at
fault ask the question right and then
look into the answer from some different
sources the truth is FDA never approved
any South Korean test for all we know
those tests aren't very high quality
there's different kinds of tests you
know they might give false positives or
false negatives that stuff matters when
you're trying to control an epidemic you
know it would be easy to just by the
South Korean test we don't do that not
because Trump said we don't want to do
it not because Trump isn't taking it
seriously
hell it's not even Obama okay it's
actually none of their fault it's just
our system okay our system is in there
for a reason
like we have a very strict system from
the FDA on what kind of tests can be
used for stuff like this
now that exists for a decent reason for
instance if people remember the I think
it's called fairness the the lady who
has sake the cancer that's absolutely
called theros yeah no I tracked on that
time because there's a is a very
interesting case that oh yeah we're in
the corporate yeah for about a million
different reasons it's a really
interesting case story and just that
fake the cancer treatment or wasn't just
cancer it was like hey you can identify
literally hundreds and hundreds of
problems that you could have medically
from a single pinprick of
right which is just just completely not
true not true just not true now going
into more detail that particular lab was
federally regulated and qualified under
a certain type of regulation through CMS
but they but not through the FDA's
regulations
okay so eventually they work all right
and that's what it's for like that's
what the regulation is for so it's still
annoying right it we should have more
tests for the coronavirus available but
our system was not designed to make that
happen quickly it should have been I'm
not saying there's not room for some
lessons learned here and some change and
we will make those changes actually the
administration frankly already has so
but the only way to do it is to get the
private sector involved and to give them
the flexibility to do the test and then
to and then to streamline the FDA's
testing of that test so that we know
it's actually a decent test you know
there was this the point is right like
stop and think and and wonder be curious
like is is it true that a test is just a
test like of course not like there's all
different types some SWAT you know I
mean it's summer lab some of our test
kits like somewhere more accurate than
others like that is it possible that
it's more complicated than the headline
is telling you is is it possible ittle
bit possible you know and and again when
I say the media does is such a
disservice it's because it's so you know
you should have somewhat of a combative
media against government it's you know
that their their point is a check and
balance against government but you would
hope that their purpose would be to
educate and that I believe that has
changed radically
I believe they don't longer view it as
there is their duty to educate the
public it's they they only see
confrontation as their duty and I don't
find that to be a good service to the
American people
I would say that is an accurate
statement the news does that or has been
doing that a lot though even like
regular local news they do that where
they land but it's not you don't click
on it but it's the same concept when
they say your is your cell phone killing
you yeah more at 11 you know so it's
like that's the fake right there
they've been doing that for a long time
yeah and then yeah then you then you
listen to it cuz you're like yeah I
listen to it and then it's like oh yeah
you know someone who dropped their cell
phone and it like made them you know do
something they killed turns out to be
like totally innocuous yeah yeah
debunked the headline speaking of
headlines next chapter sweat the small
stuff this chapter this is the chapter
where I gave you permission to complain
permission to moan and groan about the
nitty gritty small but annoying
ankle-biting inconveniences we face in
our everyday lives
permission to gripe about even your
smallest troubles grumble about long
lines at the drive-through and whine
about the imperfect weather I'm actually
going to encourage it you're welcome
okay don't thank me yet there are
certain ground rules one sweating the
small stuff is okay but exercise your
complaints lightheartedly seek out humor
and your whining be humble be self-aware
too if you're all if you allow yourself
to sweat the small stuff and I think you
should then you must also force yourself
to be detail-oriented three if you allow
yourself to sweat the small stuff then
you must try your hardest not to sweat
the big stuff what are you talking about
here what actually kind of goes back to
what you got a IIIi just restrain myself
from moving to this chapter when you set
it before when you when you got a bunch
of criticism right for saying don't be
emotional about stuff mm-hmm
and people are like well if you can't
tell me that and that makes them
emotional ironically but but in your in
your reaction was okay I'm not saying be
a robot you know I'm just saying like
don't let it get the best of you and so
I really wanted to be oh my god it's
like my chapter about sweating the small
stuff because because every time you're
told you know oh don't sweat the small
stuff and I'm like
oh I don't know about that I think
there's some venting that has to occur
and and I think we take it a little too
far in the SEAL Teams oh yeah I mean we
complain about the smallest of things
but there's like it but I and I examined
that like this chapters about examining
that truth why do we do that are we a
bunch of divas yes yes but that is then
that is true two things not is
affirmative that things can be true at
once we can be divas but there's also a
deeper reason and value to it as long as
you do it right and I try to exact I
really examine that carefully in this
chapter about what the right way is to
complain and like I try to set some
ground rules like be funny being funny
is a decent way to do things it can't be
too serious like there's a difference
between complaining about how crappy the
coffee is at the command and complaining
about the actual command atmosphere to
your guys there's there's a big
difference as from a leadership
perspective there's a difference there
like one can be kind of funny and just
like yeah stupid whatever coffees crap
and the building's stupid or whatever
like the same things people the gym
isn't hard enough there's not enough
weight cuz I'm stronger than whatever
you know typical dumb team guy
complaints there's a difference a leader
so legitimate complaints though yes
especially ya know I complain all the
time like oh guess we're at a 45 pound
plates you know my deadlift but uh the
as big as a leader especially the big
difference between that and being like
our CEO is messed up yeah that's that's
this is one of the things I talk about
leadership strategy and tactics is like
if you are just whitewashing everything
this coffee is fantastic and it sucks
you your guys are starting to look at
you going okay where does nothing real
here you're not real and you think that
you you're not question you're not
pushing back against anything
however like you said if you come down
and you say our commanding officer is an
idiot
that's gonna be problematic so you got a
you got to be careful about what you're
complaining about tools to your point
complaining forms some level of bond
right that's one of the things that we
do in the teams like we're gonna
complain about the the freakin birthing
that we have and the this that the other
thing it's like okay cool cuz we're all
on the same team we're all complaining
about it
but if somebody starts complaining about
things that matter mm-hmm at a more
strategic level now we got a problem the
other part of the don't sweat this or
the sweat the small stuff mentality is
the detail-oriented part this is really
important because one being detail
detail-oriented is an element of
fortitude I would argue I think rather
effectively and I wrapped it into this
chapter though and you could probably
wrap the detail-oriented mindset into
many of the lessons in this chapter but
I put it into this one because if you're
sweating the small stuff then by
definition you are concerned about small
things and it's not self-evident to me
that being so chillax about all the
stuff is a virtue and we sometimes see
that as a virtue like like the big and I
know like the dude from The Big Lebowski
that guy doesn't care about anything but
it's that girl other than bowling and
White Russians he was pretty passionate
about those things that is true occasion
area but um but you know it's like you
know you're you bet that that cool kid
in high school who just like let's
everything we're all off their back you
know it's like the cool surfer dude I I
got it there is I'm not saying there's
no value in that but it's not
self-evident to me that that's what we
should aspire to because it's not
obvious to me that that there are highly
productive people maybe they are not
saying they can't be but if you're not
concerned with small things there's a
pretty decent chance you're not
concerned about bigger questions in life
about bigger elements of personal
responsibility or you might not be that
motivated to to move up the hierarchy
that we talked about and so being
concerned with the small stuff is is a
habit it's an Aristotelian in the
Aristotelian sense we build good habits
that that are that are meant for a
higher purpose that's what makes them
make good have it we do it because it is
good and so that's the deeper thing here
yeah
playing a little bit like like
especially you know on the way I'm away
here we're going down as at midway Drive
mm-hmm and San Diego has often had this
problem and I've complained about it for
a very long time which is that the
lights are not synchronized they're not
synchronized for traffic flow the way
like New York City is in Manhattan those
are well synchronized lights one of my
biggest pet peeves is the lights are not
synchronized because it's it's a
solvable problem might into just
synchronize the lights mm-hmm you know
as a city manager or a mayor Robert over
at the system is and it's like as I was
going from red light to red light trying
to get to the Jacko's podcast because I
cannot be late because I just wrote in
my book that I gave him don't be late
that was funny I was like these damn red
lights you know and so my wife is like I
am so sick of hearing you complain about
that where she's like she hates this
chapter because she's she's so used to
the seal team culture
she's like why'd you even write this
like don't encourage this I'm like I am
trying to encourage it to the right
extent you know and because it is I am
walking a fine line for sure and we're
trying to we're trying to reverse some
some commonly held beliefs and it was a
fun chapter to write it was one of my
favorite yeah and obviously you just met
me that dichotomy of this is if you get
so focused on little things than you are
wasting your time you know you're
wasting your time the the Matt's on my
personal home gym my are dirty and
people say your that's you need to clean
your mats what kind of discipline is
that I'm like look I would have to spend
an hour a day clean those mats to make
them look clean maybe even more than
that I don't I don't care
it's my garage gym there's chalk on the
floor and sweat yeah that's the way it
is I'm not worried about it
yeah and that's that's a really good
point too and it's it's well it makes
especially make sense in the in the
context of the dichotomy right right
balance and like and I'm and I and I
hope that what I write there helps
people understand that there is a
balance you know it's it's don't it's
it's it's it's operating in
gray area so that you can focus on the
big stuff because you know Steel's like
to complain about wet socks like a lot
like it's a and I go into great detail
about this and we avoid wet socks that
uh you know to an extreme extent but
when it when things get really hard you
know we the complaining seems to stop
when things are really serious we
understand and have some perspective
about that and we and we act accordingly
and and I think that's perfectly
relatable to regular life you know it's
it's so it's why we go it's why we go
and do happy hours after work you know
you just you're blowing off some steam
in a healthy way it's why people go see
a therapist
like you really just you're really just
complaining to the therapist for an hour
that's that's not as they're venting
echo says yeah it's like it's like
you're just kind of letting that steam
out so that you're you're you're holding
tank of emotions doesn't explode in
somebody's face enough because that's
how you lose an eye next chapter the
right sense of shame in America today we
too often look at personal failings as
things to overcome move past or forget
sometimes we should do one or all of
those things but we should also do
something else learn our lesson the list
of public figures who run headlong into
self-inflicted failure personal
political or otherwise and then
re-emerge shameless without having
appeared to learn a thing is long don't
get me wrong I'm no opponent of
redemption far from it I certainly
believe there should be space for
re-emerging re-emergence from public
sport scorned I believe Redemption is a
trademark of an enlightened society one
of the most one of the more detestable
social trends now is mocking is the
mocking of redemption and the disc
missing of the idea that it is possible
or even desirable in place of a system
of repentance justice and mercy we have
a culture of mindless fury and outraged
culture
so you you talk about this sense of
shame
which is like a really important thing
and I looked at this from a team guy
perspective the amount of shame like for
instance if you forget a piece of gear
you when when a guy in one of my
platoons or my task unit made a mistake
I almost never had to do anything other
than simply very quietly acknowledge
that that that I saw let him know you
know and they all it takes rush the
shame would just drive them to never
make that mistake again that's what
you're talking about here that we've
kind of lost that in a sense like in a
huge in a huge sense and then the other
side of that is like hey just because
you forgot something doesn't mean I go I
don't want you in this platoon you're a
piece of [ __ ] you can get no no no no
it's like it's okay hey you made a
mistake you own it you admit it you tell
me what you're gonna do to fix it and
then we're back on the level and I'm you
know we're ready to move forward which
we don't have and then of course you go
into this whole episode that took place
with a comedian whose name is Pete
Davidson is his name yep so this is this
guy this guy is on Saturday Night Live
one night and he says they put a picture
up of you they put a bunch of a bunch of
politicians up there mm-hmm and then
they put a picture of you up and in and
this guy Pete Davidson says this guy is
kind of cool
Davidson cracked Dan Crenshaw you might
be surprised to hear he's a
congressional candidate from Texas and
not a hit man in a porno the audience
howled there as the audience howled
Davidson jumped in with a quick aside
I'm sorry I know he lost his eye in war
or whatever
so that happened via that happen I want
to and most people know that story by
now in pretty DJ I do give some
behind-the-scenes never-before-heard
elements to that story yeah you know
it's good detail which is why you got to
read the book yeah but there why is that
in the shame chapters the question I
think also I want to hear your
perspective on that whole thank you at
first because you told me a minute ago
yeah you know from my perspective it
looked like this like this just be clear
like during the election when it all
happened because I was on your show last
time well before it's ever happened
no one knew Dan Crenshaw was back then
yeah we call it Jacko's listeners well
then they did but I'm saying like when
you first came on no one really you know
you you you just started hey that was
early and yeah so it was early and but
now all of a sudden man overnight
everybody knew who you were because of
this and what happened was from my
perspective was people people started
hitting me up on social media like are
you gonna you know denounce Saturday
live and you know what did you think of
this and then they put the little thing
in there and you know of course my kind
of gut was like kind of funny you know
like my response was like kind of funny
I don't know that that made me laugh but
here's the thing
luckily for me I'm always behind on
Twitter like I'm not quite caught up and
as I finally started when I was like
okay I'm gonna respond to this right
around then and I was like man what do I
I'm like think of myself I don't think
Dan is like crying over this I don't
think he's at home going I can't believe
that some comedian like me I'm thinking
about them but people are acting as if
you were outraged they were outraged for
you and god bless him it wasn't like
they're bad people they were just
offended by it right what we do now yeah
they were offended by it and like you
and I both know I'm like hey man that's
something that probably has been said to
him a hundred times in a platoon space
somewhere you know like they don't make
fun of you for everything
so anyways when I finally responded it
was like if I think Dan can handle
himself or something I quoted you saying
hey whatever your thing which was like
hey I'm not outraged it's fine he's
literally a comedian and once again I'll
use the term literally in its project
the guy is literally a comedian he's
supposed to make fun of things and make
people laugh he's not doing political
commentary and it's not a personal
attack on you for just him just to
attack you as a human being he's trying
to make people laugh so that was kind of
my perspective it's funny how like when
you're in a position like you are and I
am in you know people like they hit you
up on social media it's almost like this
challenging like you better do this or
I'll never never like you again and if
you don't do what they want I liked you
but now now I can't or can't trust you
anymore it's just funny how that works
so that's one element of it but the yeah
the hit man in a porno thing was pretty
funny like that was that is no I don't
think that even pissed off anybody to be
honest um it was it was the the next go
here's the next comment which was yeah I
mean it was very submissive who's
actually the whatever actually the
whatever yeah yeah if he hadn't sent
that yeah he wouldn't have received any
backlash if you woulda said I'm sorry I
know he lost his eye in war it'd have
been like that's it you know what okay
cool yeah and then he said or whatever
right right and it was at a very
dismissive tone and now okay so but why
is that in that chapter and it's because
of this so the the point is is that this
the Saturday Night Live story was a
story fundamentally about showing the
right sense of shame and reaction to
that so because it could have gone a lot
different like I could have asked Jocko
to be like denounced them for me and
they're like okay fine Dan Jesus and I
could have actually stoked the outrage
and just like played the aggrieved
victim and if by the way if you read
left-wing media these days they'll say
that's all the things I did it's
actually absurd how they rewrite is
really Oh 100% it's insane
like but the lies that occur from
being media don't get me started I've
already started okay so that but that's
not what happened
right I was like my line was something
along the lines of like a you know in
this in this life like try not to offend
people but also try really hard not to
be offended so you know it's kind of
sucks what he said but now I'm not gonna
ask for him to be denounced or I don't
want I'm not demanding an apology be
careful not to demand an apology I don't
care if they apologize it's like my life
goes on either way that's sort of how I
stated that and no he shouldn't be fired
people had asked me they should be fired
like no like why you know and I'm
remembering now you also said something
along the lines of look I'm not really
offended but you may have offended other
people like you kind of took a stance
for other vets that have been wounded
has it been more grievously wounded than
you that was the important line I had to
walk on that the entire reaction because
that's legitimate total easy you can't
kind of can't forgive the guy right off
the bat you have to acknowledge that he
was screwed up and but on the other hand
you can also acknowledge that that he
may have made a mistake like he may have
misspoke like it may have been sort of
ad-libbed you know because that is a
very highly scripted show but after
working with Pete Davidson like he kind
of goes off the rails sometimes and I
mean on the show or on the ship in life
both okay obviously but you know so it's
like eight you know oh is that it's kind
of going back to be still like is there
a chance that there's more to the story
is there a chance I don't have to act
like an aggrieved victim I don't feel
like an aggrieved victim so maybe don't
act like it and so that gave that gave
SNL the space to invite me on the show
if I had really stoked the outrage mob
why would they invite me on the show you
know because now I've put them in a
corner and so you can see this going
that way and this is how it usually goes
right this code of extreme sense of
shame must be showed and the extreme
sense of or the extreme outrage
results in an extreme sense of shame
and so we've miscalibrated how we feel
shame in this country and that's a
problem for our culture and the reason
Americans liked the whole SNL moment
with me and Pete was because it was the
right balance so the right sense of
shame is about finding the right balance
of shame because it seems like we have
these like two options and and I open up
that chapter talking about all these
politicians who run headlong into
failure and then like reemerge untouched
or unrepentant at all there's a lot of
examples like that okay and I try to
have bipartisan examples by the way
because I didn't want this to be
readable to to people of other than you
know my conservative fanbase and and the
point is is that
yeah those politicians are bad people
for basically feeling no shame at the
same time our culture has given them no
incentive to feel any shame because the
outraged mob is so severe and so
unrelenting and so unforgiving that
there's no incentive to actually react
the way you should react and see you end
up just not either not apologizing or
apologizing profusely and like I
actually in the book I actually actually
analyzed this with some bell curves and
graphs that I drew it's like illustrate
this visually for people so you just
have to buy the book to see what I'm
talking about and what the point is is
like we need to get back to the middle
ground where it's like I'm kind of sorry
but I'm not really sorry you know and
there's some good examples of that like
a used Ellen DeGeneres is a great
example she took all this heat for like
you know hanging out with George W Bush
at the Dallas Cowboys game she didn't
apologize she wasn't like you know I
didn't have done like the extreme
apology I didn't realize how much pain I
would cause the LGBTQ community she
could have said that right and you've
seen other celebrities do similar things
like similar apologies it's like you've
got nothing to apologize for
nothing and she didn't apologize she she
just kind of explained it and you gotta
just put people in their place like hey
like it's cool to hang out and be
friends with people if you disagree with
and that was it novel
it was it was and it was it was a she
diffused the situation rather elegantly
and I use a couple other examples of
some good ones too but that's what we
have to be aspiring to and and we're not
there right now and then it gets into
the the chapter gets into the individual
sense of shame because this is that
that's the cultural problem we have
that's the cultural outrage mob problem
that have just described but there's a
more individualistic sense of shame too
about how you carry yourself through
your daily life and and how you have to
feel bad about something if you're going
to live your plan a like you have to
know what it is and you have to
understand right and wrong you can only
understand right and wrong if you
understand what you should feel shame
about I'm gonna and I get again into
kind of a religious discussion here
about like our morality and like how we
actually know right from wrong look this
is a this it this is a deep thing to
understand and how you should feel bad
about certain things if you're going to
live the right way and then again we we
do this meticulously in the SEAL Teams I
think I have a story in there about just
a debrief from a typical SEAL chief and
how that went you know we thought we did
good no you didn't and you're gonna feel
bad about it and you have to make
yourself feel bad about it and that's
that's that's the cycle that's the
psychological reason the psychological
underpinnings of of this chapter is is
you a seal chief or jaco can make you
know he can let you can let them know
that they screwed up right but the
question is do you feel bad about it
most team guys do most team guys like
it's just it's hard to feel like you
screwed up but in the other in the
outside world that's not always the case
a lot of people are thinking whatever I
shouldn't even be in trouble I was gonna
say since I was in a position where a
lot of times I was debriefing people and
telling them that they screwed something
up and the reactions were from a good
this is the difference use it most team
guys good team guys go man
we died up I'm gonna fix it bad team
guys go it didn't really matter that
wouldn't have that would never happen
real world I would you know like they've
got a million excuses they don't take
ownership better than they and it just
falls apart they feel no shame they feel
no shame exactly they feel like it's not
my fault it's it's not on me and and
there's a rationalization that occurs
and you have to the only thing you can
control is your conscious mind okay so
you can you can control the conversation
going on in your head about how you
rationalize that and the more you
rationalize it the less likely it is
that you actually feel the shame in your
gut because you guys at first you feel
it like you know is your fault and you
feel it but then you rationalize it away
and eventually that rationalization kind
of takes over and you no longer even
feel the shame and your gut and you're
going down a very bad path at that point
and again this this try to relate this
to very basic stuff in life like like
don't you feel bad when you're that guy
who kind of leaves the shopping cart in
a parking spot because you should yeah
you know a bad person bad person you are
you somebody's gonna hit that or it
can't park yeah or it's just a it's not
the right thing to do just a bad person
you know you did it yeah no you are
you're out there yeah you say in here we
should feel a sense of shame for not
training hard enough for sleeping in too
late for eating that extra scoop of ice
cream
we should feel regret after walking by a
piece of trash next to storm drain
knowing full well we'll go straight in
the ocean we should feel bad for not
tipping that hard working later we
should be embarrassed when we owe a
friend money and they have to constantly
remind us to pay them back but more the
team guys are listening to that one we
should feel lazy for leaving our food
tray on the table in a fast-food
restaurant even though their trash cans
are right there you go on you say we
should be in short be accountable for
everything you do
it was my commander Jocko willing echo
Charles named Joe one of my mentors and
the team's wrote an entire book on the
subject called extreme ownership the
premise of the book is quite simple
everything is your fault be accountable
take ownership take responsibility from
this responsibility
you'll find freedom it is liberating
really is it's liberating the worst
thing the worst thing is trying to look
trying to do you're gonna blame because
then you don't have control over it yeah
when you say you know what this is my
fault
then you're are free to go and make
changes in your life free to fix things
it's it's the deeper discussion about
why personal responsibility is a bedrock
of our cultural of our of our culture
and our cultural foundations and as a
conservative we always say it like I'm
always like personal responsibility and
in speeches I tried to delve into that a
lot deeper like this is actually what
this is the argument for why it matters
and it's actually quite simple personal
responsibility is empowering and lack of
personal responsibility is disempowering
the other issue is its completely
unsustainable for for a very society to
engage any lack of personal
responsibility it's unsustainable
because by definition if you're not
personally responsible someone else must
be responsible for you and that's fine
if like you're an infant or you know
you're in the might you know it's a
small segment of society right you can
you can again our our governments tries
to take that into account but if you
wouldn't actually encourage the
undermining of the foundation itself the
undermining of personal responsibility
as a virtue in and of itself which is
what's happening on the left to try to
undermine that cultural foundation
you're creating an unbelievably
unsustainable trajectory where it is
where we we have more and more people
who are who are convinced that somebody
else should be responsible for them and
therefore take their own power it's
unbelievably disempowering and it's it's
it's just I you wouldn't wish that state
of mind on anybody except your worst
enemies yeah you know it's again it's
not how you treat people you love and
it's one of those things that's tempting
right it's short-term gratification it's
it's seems like the easier way to go
because in the short term hey I just got
this and I didn't have to work for it
you know mm-hmm that's the short term
and unfortunately
we know where it ends up mmm it's like a
pyramid scheme think about it seems
saying I'm thinking about I'm I'm
getting paid or whatever cuz someone got
to do the work at the end of the day but
a pyramid scheme it's like everyone's
waiting for their turn oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then at the end of the day
everybody crashes because all who's
doing the work no no no him no not him
remember we're not doing anything no
that's right ID to think that that
person sex yeah that's what my initial
thought was trying to put it together
but yeah you're right because you're
building it on everyone's gonna get
money yeah yeah that's so it's someone's
coming from it it's basically the
diffusion of responsibility yeah this is
what you're talking about and sort of
the tragedy of the Commons as well it's
kind of a mix of all those things and
it's uh not good it's unsustainable next
chapter duty a sense of duty
my parents imbued in me a sense of duty
to do that which has inherent value you
go on to say duty is ingrained in the
human condition our great religious our
great religions are essentially based on
a sense of duty to love God and live
well we have a duty not only to survive
in this world but to pursue a higher
purpose we are here for a reason and
living for that purpose is our choice to
make it is the path to happiness so
again we're starting to talk about you
know the idea that you know you're gonna
find happiness in some short-term
gratification is not true right and this
is this this chapter comes right after
the sense of shame chapter because you
have to understand what is wrong so that
you can understand what is right and
that is that is the the darkness and the
light and you have to live in both and
sense of duty is its living your plan a
you know and I say don't live your plan
B no plan B again that I explained
before that that was about purpose
that's about living with purpose and so
we get into a lot more detail about what
that is in this chapter we talked about
the great religions we talked about why
that's important
and and then it's it's it's it's a duty
to live at the books about mental
toughness and so we bring it back into
it's a duty to live with that fortitude
and and again to feel bad as this deeply
intertwine with a sense of shame to feel
bad when you don't to understand what
that Duty is and how to live within it
and I can remember if I list the 10
commandments in this chapter or the
different chapters yeah but it's the
same kind of discussion oh no right
here's this chap it is this general
character so the and then and so that's
when I get into a really long discussion
about where our laws come from so this
this kind of goes into political
philosophy as well and the fact is is
that the Ten Commandments are the
origins of our law and I talked about
how Moses the portrait of Moses is in
the House of Representatives staring
down at the Speaker of the House and
well along with 23 other law givers but
Moses is in the middle Moses is the only
one who's not inside profile that's
important because he was the original
receiver of law not man-made law but
like absolute law these things are true
it can't be argued with they are just
true all right like Commandments one
through four basically say these are
true you can't argue with them like
believe in God and the rest of them are
like this is what you should do you know
don't steal don't kill all that and an
atheist could say welcome I know that
yeah I don't need the Bible to tell me
that I shouldn't do these things I know
they're true my counter to that is how
do you know how do you know who told you
who taught them where did you where do
they get them from how do you know
they're true and they can't answer that
they're true because they do come from a
higher power they're true because they
come from thousands of years of wisdom
and whether you believe in that higher
power or not you're still following it
and you can't escape that reality if you
start if you try to and if you start to
believe that that human morality is
changeable and that we can just choose
that to change some of those
Commandments well then you get the
Holocaust
like it's it's a short path man like
it's a short path to the horrors of the
20th century the secularism of the 20th
century killed millions tens and tens of
millions and because we untethered
ourselves from absolute morality it's a
really dangerous path yeah when you talk
about that and you end up saying at a
very basic level this is back the book
at a very basic level this is a shirking
of fundamental human duty and
responsibility a responsibility to what
exactly politeness open-mindedness and
grace for starters these are our duties
to our fellow Americans just the basics
if we lose those fundamental virtues we
lose our sense of unity without a sense
of unity under an umbrella of common
values this whole great American
experiment unravels and as you just said
we've seen this before mmm common values
exactly and and they come from somewhere
and a large part of this book is about
showing gratitude for your history
gratitude for what works I like to say
that you know again just being a
conservative conservatism is based
fundamentally on things that work things
that feel good the things that work and
that's important you know doesn't mean
we're always right but most of the time
I think at least the foundations are and
you can't just undermine the foundations
of a society and and I see that
happening more and more
unfortunately you rattle off some of
these duties you have a duty to
accomplish something every day you have
a duty to live up to your best self the
person you want to be the hero archetype
you admire you have a duty to embrace
shame and learn from it you have a duty
to be polite thoughtful patient you have
a duty to overcome your hardships and
not wallow in self-pity you have a duty
to contribute even if your contribution
is small you have a duty to be on time
you have a duty to do your job even if
your job sucks you have a duty to stay
healthy both for yourself and so you did
so that you did not become a burden on
others you have a duty to be part of the
solution not the problem in other words
don't join the Twitter mob you have a
duty to try hard not to offend others
and try harder not to be offended and
this is where you start broaching into
what I was saying earlier there is a
selfish
reason to live a life of purpose and
responsibility it will make you tougher
and more successful we aren't perfect
and we won't always adhere to these
basic duties but I hope we can start to
agree on what they are feel some shame
when we fall short and begin living our
lives with purpose this is the
time-tested formula for a stronger
people and more than that a stronger
America this is what this is what people
miss sometimes and I talk about this a
lot from a leadership perspective from a
leadership perspective if I'm a leader
that tries to climb on people's back
tries to make myself look good
tries to always shine the limelight on
myself and find the best deal for myself
if I'm that type of leader I might get
ahead for a second here there but
ultimately I will not be in charge of
anything if you're the type of leader
that takes care of your troops looks out
for the good of the mission you you look
out for everyone above yourself if
you're that type of leader look you
might take you might take hits now and
again because you're you're propping up
everyone else above yourself but in the
long run this is the this is the amazing
thing in the long run you will
absolutely be a more successful leader
than me who's over here looking out for
myself and and that's a similar thing to
what you're saying here which is like if
you do these things which seem like
sometimes they be a pain right getting
up every day and being on time taking
care of your health like all these
things that maybe you don't feel being
polite to people right sometimes you
just want to do what I want to do that
ultimately taking care of yourself and
putting yourself as the supreme cause of
your life ultimately you will be less
successful than if you take care of
other people if you treat other people
with respect if you do your job if you
do those things that again on the
surface they seem like they might not
help you in the long run you will
absolutely win absolutely and when you
win your team wins your community wins
your country wins that's what happens
right and your your individual actions
and habits and tasks that are inherently
good we have to dig and we have to kind
of redefine what good is because we've
forgotten but that makes up the fabric
of the larger culture and if we want a
successful culture that is
not at each other's throats and not
losing our minds because of
microaggressions and offenses then
you've got to live within that and yeah
treating other people with respect and
doing things for others again very basic
biblical teachings that are
unfortunately being swept away
especially in favor of a of kind of this
sense of grandstanding and sense of
morality where it's it's more moral to
demand that others do something for
others you know like that's I've thought
again I'm going back to the problems
with socialism it seems to me that
sometimes say well Jesus was a socialist
now Jesus encouraged you to be
charitable with your time and your money
right that's what Jesus said he didn't
say stand on top of a hill screaming
that other people give away their money
that's not sorry like that's that's just
your missing to deliberately
misinterpreting the teachings of the
Bible in favor of socialism like there's
a few other biblical reasons I think
socialism is not correct but but for our
purposes on this chapter that's that's a
big one sense of duty to give your time
and your money and contribute that way
and it will make you more successful in
the long run because building good
relationships is a huge part of success
we forget about that sometimes Jordan
Peterson goes into a lot of detail in
that particular element which is it's
kind of fascinating to get he's a big
fan and has he been on your show three
times times
nope he was on before he was on before
he was kind of popular yeah before 12
rules for life came out and then he was
on a two times after that and yeah
they're they're some of the most popular
episodes of the podcast until this one
of course yeah sure yeah I'm sure it's
interesting because a lot of people they
make that mistake how you're like you
have to have to do it mm-hmm because
people make that mistake with extreme
ownership - yeah yeah they're like hey
if my boss would just get on board with
this this concept you know like yeah we
problems my team would just take
ownership yeah
we're not talking about same feel and
same thing with relationships I've been
using the percentage lately of 99.9% of
the things that I got done in the
military and did in the military were
based on relationships and not based on
chain of command so every time one of my
guys you know had a mission I didn't
this is how you gonna do it no it's like
hey how do you want to get this done
every time my boss came to me they won't
like hate job this you need you know
they're like hey here's what we got what
do you think everything was about
relationships everything every the
extreme example was in the Battle of
Ramadi when we needed fire support from
tanks who needed to risk their lives to
go and get my guys prevent them from
being overrun in the field what those
tanks didn't work for me they didn't
they were in a totally separate chain of
command and yet they would do it why
because we had awesome relationships up
and down the chain of command and so
yeah absolutely relationship building is
it's it's it's critical to every aspect
of life and the little tagline that I
often tell people is relationships are
stronger than the chain of command 100
percent now 100 percent next chapter do
something hard in Budds it's all about
the next 10 minutes sometimes it's about
the next 30 seconds if you're thinking
about buds in its entirety six brutal
months then the font is simply too much
the men who quit are the men who look up
at the day before them and see all the
days to come they are thinking they're
the men who are miserable and wet and
cold and thinking about the hot coffee
and girlfriend they miss and suddenly
because they imagine the months-long
suffering they will inevitably face they
break they are already using every ounce
of endurance and fortitude to survive
what's happening right now expanding
their horizons to an infinite number of
miserable right now does them in so you
focus on the next 10 minutes and remind
yourself that the instructors can't kill
you even if they're claiming otherwise
thousands have made it before you you
can too what's on the other side of
those months and months of 10 minute
blocks are over liberation
transformation and meaning so that's
that's one way to get through buds buds
isn't six months long it's about four
minutes long right now I'm through it
lots of four minutes lots and lots of
them
we're so longer for some of us if we
extend our time by breaking a leg some
just not it not great but also normal
yeah normal a lot of people injured they
get rolled back they got to go back over
and over again so how does this how does
this apply then to you know this is
broad advice to human beings yeah so
because not everybody's going through
buds and nor should they and obviously
I'm using my own experiences here like
this was my transformation but buds is a
transformation for a lot of seals it's
what so it gives us confidence and it
you push your limits so that you way
past what you thought were there so that
you're confident enough to break past
more limits when they come because they
will come and you know they came from me
getting blown up that was there was a
limit that I didn't quite experience
even in hell week and it got worse
because things can get worse but hell
week and and buds in general and the
mentality that we developed accordingly
at least allowed me to deal with it
later
and so doing something hard it has a
number of benefits one is kind of a
simple sense of preparedness and the
Stoics a reference Stoics stoicism a lot
throughout the book and the Stoics are
referenced in this one because they day
they believed in hardship as
preparedness so that's a very that's a
very practical reason to just do hard
stuff you know if you're worried about
being homeless one day try sleeping on
the floor sometimes like try going a few
days with without the comforts of your
home so that if it did happen you'd
actually be prepared for it that that's
a very simplistic way of looking at it
but like that's what they meant by that
simple preparedness you know if you want
to be better at running a
Mountain run up a mountain like it's you
know so this is the actor preparedness
but there's a deeper reason why I think
doing something hard matters and it's
the it's the psychology of suffering and
so this is a chapter that has a lot of
Psych references in it I am did a lot of
research on this one specifically with
guy named dr. Allison from University of
Richmond and the benefits of suffering
are well documented psychologically and
physiologically physiologically speaking
interesting research that I am will go
into now but because again I want people
to read it
I don't want people that come away from
this box i spell-checked got it you know
not flying that book now thanks Jocko so
there's there's a lot more to it but um
the the suffering has inherent value and
we've we've created this society where
we try to avoid suffering and risk at
all costs and there's it's not
self-evident that that's a good thing in
fact it's pretty evident that it's a bad
thing we've become more fragile as a
result and again there's good research
that shows that we've become a kind of
this this fragile culture we need to be
anti fragile hardship should make us
stronger not just that we're resilient
to it but that it actually makes us
stronger this is this is fundamentally
true again I think think though the
Bible talks about this the psychological
research talks about this there's
there's evidence that you know again
physiological pain you know working out
it changes your brain it makes you
better at memory and if you're better at
like if your brain works better I would
argue that you're mentally tougher so
like just again so start lifting weights
you know and if you can't lift weights
like find something else that is hard so
again it's not butts and I'm not saying
lifter trauma either okay like swimming
with sharks is hard
they don't go so much sharks that's bad
butts in it so I guess what I'm saying
is don't put yourself in a dangerous
situation where you'll have to live
through a hardship and then overcome it
okay that's not what I'm saying I am
saying it has to be self-imposed
has to be habitual and there's value in
that and and it could be simple right
could be taking a cold shower on a
weekend it's like I'm just gonna
weekend's I'm gonna take cold showers
it could be waking up at 4:30 a.m. some
rather good plan yeah I hate that plan
but yeah but that's that's like but
that's there's a reason you do it you
know and it was a sense of discipline
you're on the path like this is this is
what you do and that and it's different
for everybody but just find it and maybe
make it harder the next time you know
but eventually in your case you would
just be will never I guess what would
that look like wake up earlier oh sweet
now you're just in the middle of the
night yeah it's weird I'm thinking about
there'd be some times with team guys on
operations where it goes it goes past
the normal everyday level of suck like
it starts to suck bad whatever it is
whether it's a long long insert you know
patrol in whether it's the heat whether
it's the cold whatever that thing is
like you will be I would say one out of
every eight it's just standard kind of
operations that you're going one out of
every eight you're gonna have to go into
into that zone where you look around at
the other guys and you're like yeah
you're like yep this everyone right here
everybody in this boat in this zodiac
that is absolutely freezing right now
mm-hmm
this sucks for everybody and you know
what it's just like you up we're gonna
keep going and it's like glorious and
then you look back on it later and
you're like that was amazing and it
makes you better and it it really
there's a spiritual awakening that
occurs with suffering self-imposed
suffering no doubt and and also not
self-imposed suffering I'm just saying
don't go seek out the the what you know
what would be better to refer to as
tragedy but I'm not saying seek out your
tragedy but also and now kind of be
jumping into the next chapter because
sort of leads into it but then you're
telling yourself a story about the
tragedy and there's still value in that
and again and this is backed up by
research like I did
homework on this there is whether you
call it post-traumatic growth or kind of
positive in I forget the other terms but
there's a there's a bunch of terms like
a lot psychology terms that that that
prove and demonstrate that people not
only become more resilient but but even
stronger after really hard occurrences
so don't run from it as a society we
need to embrace it
ya know no doubt in my mind and we'll
let's jump valestra let the next chapter
but first let me close this one out
because it's here's what you say in the
raw humanistic sense without suffering
there can be no internal resilience to
adversity no proper preparedness for the
future suffering controlled by you and
for the right cause can be a building
block for both spiritual health and
mental toughness in a Liberty based
nation like the United States we are
free to fail and to suffer that
fortitude is a welcomed and necessary
attribute rather than trying to erase
suffering at every opportunity we would
all be wise to value it and seek it out
so go do something hard and so this next
chapter which you are just alluding to
is called the stories we tell ourselves
you say you could tell the story of my
life as a succession of hard times and
heavy burdens you could tell it as an
array of kicks to the head interspersed
with failures my mom died my leg broke
my I got blown out my active Commission
got taken away my fellowship application
got denied all these things are
factually accurate they happened I
endured them that is where a lot of
people would leave it these are things
that happened to them from forces beyond
their control leaving it here leaving it
there communicates a handful of ideas
about someone he's unfortunate he's
unlucky he's beaten he's a victim that
is not where people should leave it
stories about burdens borne on their own
omit the most important parts the
responsibility of
individual the reaction of the
individual the growth and maturing of
the individual the world does something
to you because it will always do
something to you but once it's done that
share of the story is over that is where
your share of the story begins that's
the point where the story stops being
something done to you and starts being
about you and you go into you know we
talked about your mom dying but you
mentioned your leg getting blown there's
a lot of things that you - a lot of what
do you call them hard times heavy
burdens and failures that you talked
about in the book that we haven't even
touched and again that's why people get
the book so they can learn those lessons
and see what you went through there but
also see this you know this is now we're
getting towards the end of the book
where you're starting to tie this stuff
together and say hey listen you were in
hard you were in bad situations how what
what are you going to do in the face of
those bad situations more poignant Lee
what is the story that you tell yourself
yeah and ensure throughout this book is
a is a particular thread about
victimhood ideology and how that
pertains to outraged culture I would I
would argue that victimhood ideology is
is a tenant of outraged culture it's not
surprising that you feel really mad and
offended and angry and outraged if you
also feel like you're oppressed if you
also feel like you're a victim and you
embrace that victimhood this isn't all
that surprising either it's expected
because going back to the hero
archetypes we've elevated victims why
would just be small at pretend and make
up the story that he got attacked by two
mega hat-wearing guys in Chicago at 2:00
a.m. why would he make that up because
we've elevated victims to heroes like
that's that's why why does Elizabeth
Warren claim the lies that she's claimed
about being Native American or that she
was fired for being pregnant these are
lies they're well-documented lies you
know what's interesting is
just thinking of the which is it Jessie
I'm thinking about that guy's story if
you were to go back 20 years and someone
was gonna make up a story the story that
they would make up would be I got
attacked by two guys and I kicked their
ass yes really crazy the way our but and
that's exactly what I'm talking about
it's like that's our hero archetypes
have shifted so wildly that that the
more likeable story is getting your ass
kicked and then complaining about it as
opposed to like no I just whupped their
ass like that's exactly that's a that's
a perfect point to make and it in like
you know that's why I start the book
with who is your hero cuz it's such an
important concept and in this case it's
like okay now that you know who your
hero is well then you should you should
identify how you react to hardship not
saying hardship doesn't exist victim you
know when I bash victimhood ideology I'm
not saying there are no victims it is
possible that you truly are a victim by
salutely but you know but one that
should be defined like in just the word
injustice needs to be defined better so
that we can overcome outrage culture and
injustice doesn't mean things that
aren't fair or things that you don't
like unfortunately that's how the word
is used all too often and justice means
someone needs someone else is truly
infringing on your rights rights defined
as life liberty and property okay
injustice can be defined as your due
process being taken away some some true
unfairness or discrimination being
implemented against you that can be
defined as injustice okay an outcome
based on something other than your merit
can be defined as an injustice but but
victimhood ideology really turns these
that really strains these definitions
and I think people understand know this
intuitively just watch the news and
watch how people are reacting on social
media this is a really big problem it
prevents us from telling the right
stories about injustice and then solving
it and overcoming it it's we've been
encouraged to live in the story of
victimhood when something bad happens
and that may feel good again
back to what you're saying before this
sort of short the the short-term
thinking it feels good in the short term
right it feels like feels like it's
somebody else's fault and there's
there's a comfort in that it's like a
warm blanket of self-pity that occurs in
like comforting but it's also it's it's
you could almost say quite literally
killing you because it leads you down
this path of despair that that ends in
not a good place if you always feel this
your things are out of your control and
you're disempowered and then if you
literally cannot get better you'll not
get better one of the questions that I
get asked a lot when working with
companies they'll say you know what's
the biggest obstacle for having a
culture of extreme ownership and it's
really easy answer the answer is the ego
because when something goes wrong and
you have to say hey this is my fault
well that hurts your ego and that's the
biggest thing that people have to
overcome now the other thing that that's
interesting is and you address this here
so the other thing other question I'll
get asked a lot when it comes to extreme
ownership and I've kind of already
mentioned it you know is hey if my kid
gets sick how do I take ownership of
that if I get cancer how do I take
ownership of that if the market falls
apart and we lose all of our money I
have to let people go how do I take
ownership of the of the market how do I
take ownership of a natural disaster
that occurred right so there's good I
get asked that question and the response
is you take ownership of how you how you
respond to that occurring right when
something bad happens and you you you
you go through the same thing here you
say even if I was not totally
responsible for what happened I was
still responsible for what would happen
mm-hmm and this is after you got after
you got removed from the Navy anything
they didn't kick you out of where they
force you to retire right now they
forced you retire look death that's just
happening to you like the big blue Navy
is going you're done and you can't
control it and so
do you take ownership of that you you
take ownership by how you respond to
that and what you say here's you try and
find your next mission right you can
control the next step there's another
important point here that I that I lay
out which is the way you describe your
history this is important as putting
yourself in the right psychological
framework and we call those get to
statements like I have to wear an eye
patch or I get to wear an eye patch you
know because it looks cool so that's
nice
all right get to wear the gold tried n
tie because it looks cool but you can go
much deeper than that like I you know in
some of the to an extent this is
self-deception right and and you know
that consciously going going into it
like you know because I use another
example like well I I have to pay my
bills or get to pay my bills because it
shows that I'm an adult and I'm living
responsibly I have to pay taxes or I get
to pay taxes that one's harder that
one's things live in California yeah
guys all you do is pay taxes yes we do
um doesn't pay tax and they're not even
synchronizing the lights because if you
get to pay taxes that means that you've
made enough money yeah to pay taxes so
I'm saying in in a different country by
the way yeah
I mean it's you know it fundamentally
what you're doing there is finding the
silver lining because the finding the
silver lining in a bad situation is
fundamentally about telling yourself a
different story about that situation and
so it's it's not whistling past the
graveyard you know it's it's it's it's
not it's not ignoring the actual
hardship
it's just forcing yourself to have the
fortitude to tell yourself the right
story about it that that's that that's
what the chapter is fundamentally about
yeah um and it's one of those things you
you you read through it you go yeah this
is the attitude that you would want a
kid to have you know you close it out
here 20 years ago I received a letter in
the mail from Rice University the letter
might as well have been addressed dear
failure because it was indeed a letter
informing
that my services were not required at
the prestigious school I failed to get
in 20 years later I became the US
congressman who represents Rice
University the path from that failure to
my present-day success was not an easy
one many more obstacles and failures
would present themselves every day each
against a small obstacle against each
small obstacle I had to tell the right
story in order to stay on the path
through self-fulfillment failure like
suffering has intrinsic value and worth
should we choose to confront it properly
otherwise the ultimate story of success
whatever that may be for you will never
get told the other element here and I'm
going to listen to that much detail but
it's an answer I give when especially
kids ask how to deal with hardship and
I'd like to point out that every
obstacle is an opportunity and that
sounds kind of cliche but it but it's
really not it's true I wouldn't be a
congressman if I hadn't gotten my eye
blown out this is true I would have
stayed in the teams never would have
left I had no reason to leave it was
night I fought very hard not so best job
ever why would you leave yeah and if I
hadn't have been there's so many things
like it I talked about you know got
denied this cool White House fellowship
if I had gotten that I wouldn't be a
congressman you know so technically
that's a failure but you know you also
also it's not oh well what did you go
for that fellowship right after Harvard
right after Harvard was right after the
Navy for one year applied for that
didn't get it you applied for the White
House fellowship right and you didn't
get it didn't get it and then you're
like okay cool can't beat them join them
well no so ran for Congress cuz now I
control the funding for the White House
fellowship yeah yeah that's right
Naval Academy didn't well I guess it was
actually you can't join them beat them I
guess yeah yeah I didn't join them sorry
you didn't get in the Naval Academy
either no didn't get in the into the
Naval Academy um
rejected I'm not going to defund the
Naval
I mean but but but no I didn't get in
and what if I had I don't know maybe I
wouldn't have even made it to buds you
know you could argue you know it's just
different selection process like there's
all these you want to hear a little
story that I tell myself whenever I get
some kind of like little injury even if
it's like a a more significant injury
maybe it's something that's gonna make
take me out of off my training schedule
for a month right hurt my knee hurt my
shoulder or something I always tell
myself that that was the greater powers
way of getting me to not Train cuz the
next day I was really gonna get hurt
yeah the next day I was tough so I'm
just like okay cool
that's God's Way of telling me I'm not
supposed to train right now because
otherwise I was gonna break my neck or
something so we're just gonna that's
right that's the story I tell myself
sometimes I think it's a I mean it's not
a joke I think it's a real I believe in
that kind of stuff honestly I Bible I do
believe that um some things happen for a
reason it's up to you to actually react
to it appropriately but I don't know I
actually do believe in that and I think
that comes out in this in this chapter
it's one extent all right next chapter
you went from the personal story now
we're talking about the story of America
this is this is chapter 10 the
individual stories we tell ourselves not
just about our hardships but about who
we are combined to create our American
story every one of us adds a small
thread to the larger fabric of our
culture and as we change and evolve so
do our cultural norms the American story
itself evolves this isn't a bad thing
either it is natural and constant
throughout history but something is
changing for the worse the American
story itself is being threatened our
cultural fabric has often changed and
evolved but it has never been
irreparably torn the closest we ever
came was a civil war
I suggest you that the latest threat to
our American story is outraged culture
identity politics and victimhood
ideology that it
elevates the threat is born of small
beginnings as big threats so often are
it starts with toxic personal narratives
wrapped in cheap cloth of victimhood
always looking to X to an external
culprit to blame for real or perceived
injustice
so this is the direction you fear that
we are heading right now I think we're
there so pessimistic well it's just well
I'll tell you one things I knew you
talked to I was going to say I was just
like when I was I was on with Ben
Shapiro and I just went up and talked to
Candice Owens and you know they live at
Ground Zero for interacting with crazy
people I mean and you're I'm there
you're not think it becomes all you see
as you get a little bit more pessimistic
exactly and and you know I'm really
lucky because you know I work with a
bunch of different umpah knees all over
the country and work with every
different type of company and work with
all levels inside of a company so I'm
not just out there only talking to the
CEOs and the see sweet I'm also out
there talking to frontline troops
communicating with them talking about
what problems they have so we really get
to see and everyone at national in front
we really get to see the pulse of not
only of America over a large span but
and a bunch of different socio-economic
levels and in a bunch of different
industries whereas I mean Candice and
and Ben like they go to they go to speak
at colleges that's kind of what they do
you know and well you're not gonna run
into the same type of people that I'm
gonna run into that's working on a
construction site or a manufacturing
plant in Iowa no you're sure not and I
do the same thing I've been pleasantly
surprised to be perfectly honest with
you even when I go to colleges and
especially high schools I think the
questions are good there's disagreement
it's been it's been good yeah actually
now that you mention it call just
sometimes too and you and you mentioned
you know you were talking about the kind
of crowd that comes in to CMU the
crowd that comes in to see Candace Owens
or Ben Shapiro sure there's people that
want to see them that have like a
conservative viewpoint but they probably
attract at least as many if not more
lunatics to do and it's I have seen it
happen less over time also because you
know they've been in Candace and Charley
Kirk day that is kind of what they're
looking for because they want the debate
to happen on camera
I personally I enjoy it too like I want
I want people on the left to come and
debate me
mm-hm and I'm gonna you know that's what
I want that's it's one of the reasons
I'm doing it if it's just a bunch of
people they're agreeing with me that I'm
not I'm not making a lot of progress
it's really just a rally at that point
and there's value in that too but but we
are going there for the confrontation I
just want it to be respectful and
fact-based and and and it's not always
that way I've had some interesting
experiences where it's just it just
devolves into an emotional ramblings but
I felt so had some really interesting
public debates and like that's kind of
unusual for a politician to do see
that's the candice owens and ben shapiro
model it's unusual for a politician to
do because we can get in so much more
trouble doing it because it's dangerous
yes it's it's you don't know how that's
gonna go people setting up ambushes on
you yeah gotcha moment right
right and so just be prepared for it and
you'll be fine know what you're talking
about you know it's it's and so I do it
and it's um but uh I enjoy it quite a
bit so that you know but okay but back
to the original question which is are we
are we there as a culture and the answer
is kind of like it's worse than it used
to be how about that you know whether
whether we're like we're in a disaster
area right now with respect to
victimhood ideology and identity
politics that's up that could be debated
forever and it kind of depends on what
your standard is like whoa what does it
look like to be over the edge on that
like I'm not sure I just know it's worse
I just know it's gotten a lot worse and
other and III referenced Jonathan Hyde
quite a bit in this book one of my
favorite authors and his book the
coddling of the American mind is a great
read if you're if you're really looking
to examine how this evolved on college
campuses and they can really examine it
down to the year
about 2013 which and then they examine
all the reasons for this you know this
sort of outraged culture and even then
though they they they point out it's
it's mostly at the coastal elite
institutions it happens a lot less on
other college campuses where listen the
reality is most college kids just want
to get drunk and like get through their
next class and you know that they're not
super hyped up about politics the social
media the fact and those of us who live
within the world of social media also
makes us believe that like you need you
that it's a lot worse than it really is
and you have to remove yourself from
that and so you won't see me using
examples in this book of people on
social media you'll see me using
examples from leaders in our country and
like big you know big media companies
like the New York Times you know really
pushing these narratives so I'm not
getting my my evidence for this problem
from random commentators even if I could
count thousands of them because it's
like what are thousands a tiny tiny
little itty bitty fraction in the United
States what matters is the leaders and
how that's changed over time so that's
why I come at this and I say you know
what there is a real problem here and
we're there because our leaders are
talking like this like this is a bigger
movement than just some idiots on
Twitter it's bigger than that and so
that you know that's so that's why I
think it's such a because it gives if I
couldn't find those examples then then I
would argue that yeah maybe I'm over
blowing it but the victimhood ideology
is a it's here and I could you know from
what you just read the argument I'm
making there unless you were gonna go on
to something else
go ahead see the argument I'm making
there is that there's a series of steps
that have led to this moment where we're
telling a different story about of
America and I give an analysis of
analysis of how its victimhood ideology
that's created there's a lot of elements
but victimhood ideology is a big one
it's because it firsts are small as I
note there it's of small beginnings
where you're blaming somebody else like
maybe it's your platoon commander who
just didn't see the value in you
way they should have mm-hmm which by the
way if you talk to modern military
commanders is a problem with you know a
younger generation like they're seeing
these differences in how it is to manage
troops it's it's just it's different
it's hard it's hard it's not the same
like I came into the SEAL Teams thinking
okay like I have to I feel like I have
to earn my way here newer newer maybe
team guys maybe not team guys but
definitely the military newer troops are
thinking like they're owed more than or
their the organization itself has a duty
to them but not the other way around
like a duty to give them more
responsibility and and leadership or
whatever and but but they haven't quite
burned it yet like more status without
earning it yet this is something we've
this is something when I talk to leaders
I don't I'm curious what your perception
is on this because you talked to so many
corporate leaders and how it is to to
manage the different generations not
only corporations but also still talking
to military troops and there's always
people well this is a question that I
get asked all the time and it's you know
what's wrong with my team mm-hmm and you
could probably guess how I answer that
this is a leadership problem and well
one of the things I'd fall back to all
the time
so I don't know that I can think of a
more difficult workforce to deal with
then being then dealing with draftees in
Vietnam in the Vietnam War people that
did not believe in the cause did not
want to do the job and in doing the job
their life and limb was at risk you
cannot think of a more difficult work
force to try and deal with so I've read
many many many many many books about
Vietnam I've interviewed many Vietnam
veterans leaders and and troops and
here's the deal good leaders good
leaders and my first example is colonel
david hackworth who's like my my
personal mentor you
I never met him but I read his book many
times and all this books many times but
when he talks about the draftees and he
was he was in Korea and he was in
Vietnam he's a battalion commander in
Vietnam he was one of the most decorated
guys ever and when he would talk and he
was a complete lifer this guy worshipped
the army it was the oh he was in the
military since 15 years old it was all
he ever knew and when he would talk
about his draftees and when he talks
about him in his book about face he
loved his draftees and he loved his
draftees because guess what they would
call it they would call [ __ ] when
they didn't think he was making a good
call they would give him pressure
against what he was saying to do if it
didn't make sense they would test him
they would push back and as a leader he
thought that's exactly what I want
that's exactly what I want is I don't
want people I don't want a bunch of
robots I had one of his company
commanders on the podcast who retired as
a general Mucca Mucca Yama general
ookayama fantastic guy and I asked him I
said he was a company commander in
Vietnam and I said what because I this
is this question I hear all the time I
said you know sir what did you think of
your of your draftees in Vietnam and he
said I I really couldn't tell who was a
draftee and who wasn't and so then you
read other books and what it boils down
to is and most of the books the other
books that I read are like interviews
with people and if you have leaders that
are not good leaders guess what they do
they complain about the draftees about
how they they push back they didn't
follow orders people like William Calley
in charge of the meal I mascar what did
he think he hated draftees because he's
a shitty leader and so when you talk to
me about a millennial that the
characteristics of a millennial hey they
they they think they deserve stuff they
want to know why they're doing what
they're doing they wanted to have
ownership of stuff they think they
deserve to be in charge of stuff and I'm
like bring me that new guy I'll take
that new guy any day of the week and
I'll take that new guy and be like okay
you want you want to run something you
won't know it you wonder why you're
what you're doing absolutely you deserve
that that's decentralized command you
need to know why you're doing what
you're doing perfect you want to take
ownership and stuff absolutely
you you think you should be in a higher
elevated position good
let's get you there so we can always
complain about the junior generation the
freaking kids and the teams right now
are way better than I was when I checked
in as a new guy are you kidding me
they're way better they're tough
bastards - it's not like they're just
more technically you know some people
say well you know the new generation is
more tech-savvy it's like yeah they are
and they're tough as hell so when we
start talking about what the problems
with is with our troops what a good
leader does it says okay there's these I
need to treat this guy with I need I
need to make some maneuvers here to get
this person on board with the program
because it's not like some young army
guys like I don't want to do a good job
it's not like some person at a tech
company some person that just graduated
from college and went to a tech
companies like you know what I don't
want to do well here like no they want
to do well now they might have some high
visions of themselves cool whose job is
it to put those visions into check whose
job is explained to them listen man I'm
glad you want to step up and run
everything that's awesome
let me ask you this do you even
understand how this you know how the
economy of our business is working right
now if you explain this here look at
this look at this spreadsheet and
explain what this means I have no idea
okay cool let's get you educated on this
let's get you to learn this cuz you know
what I do want you to elevate I want you
to take over this company that's fine
but you've got to learn this stuff I
think so as a leader we got a we got to
look at people and this is again this
happens all the time and it happens
within wonpil tune you know I guarantee
you had guys in your platoon that fought
they knew everything and you had some
guys that were like happy to be here and
they're just humble you get you get all
these guys you get all these guys and is
there some little difference in the
generations sure there's always
difference in the generations no
freaking generation was as hard as mine
right we always hear that you know the
guys when I got to the teams it was like
the guys from the 70s were like oh the
guy
in the 80s a week and then the guys in
the ad said the guys from the 90s a week
like let's just keep going how do we
reflect things as a leader make
adjustments when if my team is not
performing well I'm a hundred percent
responsible for it if my team has a bad
attitude I'm a hundred percent response
before it and I'm gonna get it fixed
that's what I'm gonna do I'm responsible
to do that yeah and that's it
that's a very nuanced look at this I'm
always asking this question because I'm
a millennial you know it's silly and
it's hard to generalize a generation
you just can't but but you have to -
there are stereotypes exist for a reason
so it's it's it's good for analysis to
try and figure that out and and I don't
know I don't know where I fall on it
because I see the I see I do see some
bad aspects it's an you know wanting
more responsibility was maybe the wrong
thing to to hit on as a negative
attribute that's obviously a good thing
but it also but sometimes it's
accompanied by a not so humble belief
that that somebody is victimizing them
and preventing them from moving up
because of some kind of oppression and
that's and if I get someone like that on
my team who's responsible for fixing
that attitude I I can promise you right
now we'll play the question game all day
long and I do this I do this with every
level of leadership I have people coming
you know my team's all jacked up okay
cool
who's in charge of your team well yeah
that's right you are or someone say my
frontline troops aren't doing 100 who's
in charge your front
frontline troops it's bill okay who's in
charge of Bill Mike who's in charge of
Mike me that's right you you're
responsible for what's going on down
there and if there's attitudes that you
don't like man you're responsible for it
now you are absolutely responsible for
it and if you're a good leader you can
get those attitudes to shift in the
right direction and generally by doing
exactly what we're talking about when
and you and I were having a conversation
earlier it's like if they understand why
these decisions are being made or why
they actually need to learn some of
these frontline jobs before they can
move up the chain of command if they
understand that they have a path
for mobility - to increase their pay and
increase their responsibilities inside
of an organization okay okay cool thank
you for telling me that and now I'm
gonna go get after it as opposed to
millennial suck yeah and I kick and I
can't I can't deal with no it's like
okay cool yeah okay I mean I guess it's
I guess that's why I wrote the book
right because because I do see these
things as problems and I don't see them
in my team my team is great and they're
Millennials or younger so obviously
something is working there maybe that's
because I hired the right people with
the right temperament who's in charge of
doing that well me exactly exactly so
when you when you meet someone that says
oh I got these horrible people on my
team Oh
have you tried to fix them yeah but I
can't fix them well a whose fault is
that B who actually hired these people
in the first place if you if you can sit
down with someone and you interview them
or you hire them and then they're
horrible and they have a horrible
attitude and they don't want to be a
part of the team great you're not gonna
be a part of my team yeah you're not
gonna be a part of my team if that's if
that's what you bring to the table and
so and so this book I think is like what
I'm trying to do is look at a broader
cultural problem because it is it it is
and and then try to give lessons to fix
it you know because for all the reasons
you just stated it's like it's it's we
have to take ownership of our culture as
well it's not just 200 our team that we
can you know you should of course and
that you can control a lot when you're
leading a team but we've got to come
together as a culture and be better
because as I as a part you read as an
individual you're an individual thread
and the larger fabric of society and our
culture is being transformed and not in
a good way and I hope the problem isn't
as bad as I kind of make it out to be
but um you know what worst case scenario
I'm wrong and and things are going in a
great deal
I wouldn't say worst case scenario
you're wrong
I mean clearly there are indicators of
what you're talking about and as you
said you're not talking about people on
Twitter you're talking about mainstream
yeah
organizations that that proceed in this
direction in the analysis because I went
on off on a tangent talking about
Millennials and the management issues
with them so the analysis I go into is
it goes something like this you believe
in a victimhood ideology believe that
somebody else is to blame
maybe beats your team maybe it's our
boss maybe it's your parent maybe it's
your teacher whatever it is somebody
else's fault okay you're in that you're
living that story about yourself
individually that is expanded it's
expanded to groups it's expanded to this
sort of group on group identity politics
not my fate is tied to an immutable
characteristic that is tied to a group
maybe it's race maybe it's gender maybe
it's socio-economic in nature and by by
consequence there is another group
oppressing my group okay so it's group
on group politics this is identity
politics to the courts it's it's the
promise of more power from one group to
another okay you're telling somebody
they're a victim and you're telling them
that you're the champion of them against
the oppressors so that's the next thing
but then it evolved even more than that
it evolves into these kind of
institutional conflicts and so it's not
just a group that's oppressing you that
group is tied to a broader institution
maybe that institution is the church
maybe that institution is is some kind
of you know cultural institution maybe
it's a merit merits and maybe it's a
meritocracy that to me that's an
institution this notion that we compete
based off of merit and that your reward
is tied to how well you perform or your
talent right the meritocracy is an
important institutional construct in our
culture okay
there's other institutions too like the
Supreme Court when we're talking about
packing the Supreme Court you're talking
about tearing down an institution those
government institutions there's cultural
institutions there's social institutions
you know the the word institution is
malleable in that sense and it should
describe a kind of a cultural framework
that we operate and I think those come
under attack you know because it's it's
the institution's fault I talk about um
Thomas Sol he's an economist and Hoover
Institute and Stan
amazing amazing thinker and author he
talks about how the French Revolution
was they that the led by Rousseau who
was free it was it was based on this
idea that the natural state of things
involves no suffering but that it is
institutions that caused suffering well
that's a really interesting concept it's
like this belief that that life is
actually it is not it is not natural in
life to to be oppressed or to be to go
through suffering
it is not natural what is natural it is
and it is the unnatural institutions
man-made institutions that created your
suffering
therefore we must revolutionize those
institutions tear them down and build
our utopia this was how the French
Revolution happened this is how 17,000
people were dead in the next few years
from the from the terror that ensued it
is the thinking that led to Marxism and
the horrors of the 20th century all
right this is this isn't all that
controversial of a statement to make
it's just kind of how it happened and
that that is how that is how the
progressive left thinks as well that it
is these these it comes from somewhere
like progressivism has a history just
like conservatism has a history and it
is it is a history based on this kind of
your your feelings are correct if you
feel something it must be right and and
you should and the injustice is against
you are always man-made and they're
always come from an oppressor they're
never a natural part of life therefore
government is there to fix those
institutions and that's why you must
proceed with the revolution this is the
thinking that occurs ok so that ends up
once you've torn down the institutions
there's another ultimate oppressor and
it's the american founding itself that's
the story of America that keeps getting
told and that worries me a great deal we
didn't used to fight about that the left
and the right did not fight about the
story of America the way we're fighting
about it now and it's become this
question of whether America was have
been founded on anything good at all
that's a pro that's that's the story
being spun and it stems from this
individual victimhood identity politics
and again I'm not making this up I'm not
because I'm looking at major leaders
that say these kind of things you know I
quote bado
I quote Ilhan Omar America was founded
on genocide not not that America
committed genocide that would be an
accurate statement you know but America
was founded on it
that implies a very different meaning
saying that white supremacy is a problem
is a true statement saying we were
founded on it that's a different
implication you're you're indicted the
american founding itself so what does
that lead to well it leads to popularity
with burning the American flag please
the popularity with kneeling for the
national anthem it leads to popularity
with with with with attacking the Pledge
of Allegiance as an institution in and
of itself it leads to it leads to the
New York Times public is just okay on
the 4th of July like it leads you know I
open up in this chapter talking about
the the New York Times going after the
Apollo 11 50th anniversary basically
praising the USSR instead of America on
this day it's like why is that why is
that the reaction because because
there's this need to to tear down the
institutions of America at its core why
is that well because you need to tear
something down at its core if you want
to implement the revolutionary utopia
that you envision so this is the most
political chapter by far right this is
where I really delve into the
differences like the real deep
differences between conservatism and
progressivism because I I nailed
conservatives a little bit on this too
as far as the victimhood ideology goes
like it's a different form of ideology
it's a different form of victimhood but
it occurs and it's sort of in and it
occurs up to the up to the limits of
tearing down institutions ok
conservatives have a very inherent
distrust of government institutions like
sometimes to a conspiratorial degree but
we stop wasting the founding of America
and then the solutions to this problem
which is what I really and the
after with I make a very strong argument
for against against progressivism as a
solution to these problems mostly
because progressivism at its heart is a
promise to end your suffering and that
is an inherently dishonest promise to
make for the reasons I just say again
that's the the basis of the French
Revolution we can end your suffering
because it's man-made it's not natural
the natural state of things is for you
to live in a wonderful utopia prancing
around in the trees or whatever the heck
they were imagining it doesn't make any
sense because it's not real and so to
tell somebody that you will in their
suffering to tell them that you can
replace God with government because what
is what is what is religion
fundamentally it's like the Jesus took
on the crucifixion and the the The
Passion of the Christ is about him
taking on the suffering because there's
a spiritual element to this and it and
that and that can't be that can't be
replaced by a government ideology and
fundamentally it's its basic level
that's what progressivism attempts to
promise people and I also tried to
define what I mean by the progressive
movement very carefully in the book
because I don't want there's a lot of
people who identify as progressive
because you know they just got back from
a gay wedding or they like to smoke some
pot or they like tattoos or whatever or
they do yoga you know like like that's I
I've defined that very carefully as
social progressivism in the modern sense
and like that's just not what we're
talking about here I'm talking about the
deeper underlying politics and history
of the progressive movement and what
it's fundamentally promising people
talking about the role of government in
your life and you know because again I
want this to be readable to a lot of
different people but this is the most
political chapter by far you know one
thing that speaking of the tattooed yoga
whatever person I was a really
rebellious kid right and I think at some
point there's gonna have to be like a
like a Republican with a mohawk and face
tattoos
that's gonna come out and say like hey I
have face tattoos I like whatever genre
of underground subculture music I don't
want to conform to anything and the best
way to live that life is to actually
support conservative values because
conservative values support individual
freedom and that's what I believe in
yeah and I think that's what's gonna get
some of these cuz let's face it
an 18 year old kid wants to be
rebellious why because they trying to
get out of the house they're trying to
show their dad but they don't need them
anymore trying to show their mom they
don't need them anymore so I'm leading a
mohawk and we're gonna tattoo on my neck
and I'm gonna move forward into the
world and and other kids look around
okay that's how we're rebelling but at
some point you go actually it just blows
my mind that people say you know you go
up to anyone and say um you know do you
want the government to be in charge of
anything you go up to someone with a
mohawk and if yeah or whatever and
they're like no way man no way man and
then you go cool why would you vote for
the government to be in more charge of
more of our lives I just don't think
that connection gets made often enough
no it doesn't and I deal with this often
and since I talked to most not mostly
but um I'm a politician who there's a
lot more youth engagement than most
politicians do
and so I address this directly like how
do you as a conservative young person
how do you make the case for
conservatism to your your fellow young
people who kind of live by this kind of
libertarian and what you described as
sort of a libertarian an extra
rebellious libertarian these people who
kind of live by this notion of you know
social progressivism and freedom but but
fundamentally they believe in a kind of
Republican form of government that is
out of your life and you know fiscally
responsible you know they they live by
this mantra well I'm socially liberal
but fiscally conservative right that's
what people say and then they vote
Democrat 100% like almost
100% of the time so it's it's a mantra
that makes them feel good but it doesn't
mean anything to them and I mean delving
into this is like my life's work at this
point yeah I feel something so I'm so
glad I don't have to talk about the
stuff okay I'll do it once a year with
you but it's a super interesting thing
and you're like like why why is your
entire vote your entire vote on a
political party based on the abortion
issue I mean it doesn't make sense it's
not it's not a rational decision I'm
sorry it's just not especially because
that issue will not affect you you know
because you because people will say this
and they've got like three kids and
they're like well and they would never
get an abortion themselves it's like
this doesn't affect you at all you know
you can make a pretty good argument this
should be decided at the state level and
yet you are voting 100% because of this
issue at the federal level this is not a
rational decision and or gay marriage
it's like that's definitely not a
rational decision considering it's not
even argued about anymore
like that's the Supreme Court's done
with that one so it doesn't you know
it's it's really surprising to see how
people think about these things and and
so I guess bring it back to the book my
point is I'm trying to distinguish there
I'm trying to distinguish this into a
role of like what our intuitive
conversation about what government is
actually for and how that manifests into
victimhood ideology how that manifests
into the story about America because
again I can make it it's a very short
path from victim and ideology and in
America as an oppressor to hatred of
America itself and I only I only quote
the big ones I only quote you know
Taylor Swift because she's a cultural
icon you know and she's out there saying
if you're not a cisgender white male
your rights are being stripped away
that's a Taylor Swift quote that's an
amazing thing to say from one of the
most successful prosperous people in the
world why would she believe that what is
happening that she believes this thing
that is so fundamentally not true that
is so easy to to debunk why would she
believe this why did a OC believe that
she's the next one I quote which is like
what did she say my generation has never
known American prosperity
how does that make any sense I mean it
only makes sense in this context where
if God are you really insane yeah it
only makes sense when you understand
that the goal is to elevate victimhood
and then they use that and then they use
that to tear down the story of America
itself and it's a it's it's such a
dangerous path that we're on that we
want to revolutionize the foundations of
our prosperity to such an extent and
again the only way to justify the only
way to make people believe that their
eyes are lying to them that all the good
things around them are just lies the
only way to make them believe that is to
constantly is to constantly hammer them
with this crisis narrative with this
false narrative that people are trying
to oppress them or there's other people
being oppressed and you've never met
them but guess what it's happening and
if you don't and if you don't raise your
fist against the injustice then you're
part of the problem you and your white
privilege it's this is happening in such
an extreme level you know and it's and
again the good news is is like people
listening like well I haven't seen it
and look good that's good but it is
happening
ya know I mean you gotta be aware like
you said there's evidence big evidence
from from real players out there that
that preached this and and live this
sort of life it's kind of interesting
man because we on this podcast
very seldom talk about politics at all
and yet people kind of know where I
stand and they kind of you know just
it's all good well like you said it is
real things that is going on um it is a
problem and that's the one thing that I
would say is very nice about your book
is that it is a first of all it explains
it and it gives some pretty good answers
on how to move forward and one of the
things you do is you you close out with
with an American ethos ya set you set
forth an American ethos in the book or
what I think you called a draft or you
say perhaps it goes something like this
and you and you spell it out pretty
straightforward
nothing that really anybody would
sensibly argue with right you know
nothing that you could really sensibly
argue with and I'll let people get the
book and and and read it but you know
that the last line of it is you know I
will live with fortitude you know name
of the book is fortitude that's sort of
a last line of the American ethos that
you you put forth and that's a simple
statement right it's a simple statement
but it's something that you can actually
carry with you in every part of your
life and the way you tie fortitude into
all these other aspects of how to deal
with other people how to react to things
that is what the book is about and it
really sets forth a a great path for
people to go down to get their
themselves their family their country
into a more stable and productive and
better place so I've read a tiny
fraction of the book today
whoever you what you should do is order
this book right now now here's something
that you haven't ran into yet Dan your
publisher your publisher is first of all
they're under estimating you they're
under estimating the people that want to
hear this message so they're only going
to print X amount of books mm-hmm
they're looking at pre-sales they're
like okay we're gonna print X amount of
books because it's an investment it's a
risk for them and then what happens is
the book comes out people start to read
it it catches on fire and then all of a
sudden they're four weeks out from
printing more books so what people need
to do right now is pre-order the book or
your book which makes the publisher then
print more also I should note all
pre-orders are getting a signed book
plate oh all of them ouch yeah my hand
hurts yeah
that's not fun ah so order the book
right now we'll have it on our website
so you guys can click through and order
it well I need to clarify that you have
to go to Dan Crenshaw book.com slash
pre-order to upload your receipt so that
we know you pre-ordered it and can
should get you the bookplate you know
what we if you do that you get the book
playing I've been I've been putting out
that website pretty conical I'm gonna
take this as a personal challenge to see
if I can break you get so many freakin
pre-orders that you have to sign book
plates for like
this this I mean do something hard you
know sign 1 million book plays yeah do
something art that is nasty you actually
have a podcast now your own podcast
which is called hold these truths yeah
tell us about that podcast a little bit
so I'm always looking for ways to
communicate it's my job I've got to
communicate the truth and the policies
that I believe are right and the things
we're voting on in Washington so I do
that a ton on social media everybody
knows that and there's there's you know
there's a different method of
communicating for every platform and one
thing that you can't do on Instagram and
Facebook and Twitter is have really
lengthy conversations and deep dives
into policy issues so I do that on the
podcast and you know it started because
I'm like you know I get these 5-minute
conversations during hearings when I
have a really interesting witness come
and talk about something and maybe I'll
meet with that person later too and it's
a really interesting conversation and I
ask some you know questions that I need
answered
whatever why don't we record that why
don't we dive into these things and so
what you'll find from that podcast is a
whole variety of issues you know one day
it'll be at about Iran or China another
day it'll be about student loans I've
interviewed the previous head of the
ACLU we'll talk about free speech we'll
talk about you know this discrimination
law makes sense in these in these
conditions like there's there's some
really fascinating deep dives we'll talk
about 5g will talk about Bitcoin I mean
there's a whole variety of things
Medicare for all the environment the
green New Deal like all of this stuff
and talking to actual experts on the
subjects as I say that's your job gives
you access to people that actually know
what they're talking about yeah yeah
they'll come and talk to me and are you
bringing on people that you don't agree
with well I've gotten into debates with
some for sure especially a head of the
ACLU we haven't we probably could do
more of that it just
started so I'm trying to build up a
bleib rarey right now of just deep dives
into certain policies or I'm kind of
just asking the questions as a because
you know the way we went at this podcast
he was like I don't have time to prepare
for it and I'm too busy to take the time
to really prepare a podcast the way you
are preparing your podcast each time
it's it's not it's not feasible for me
well it's more feasible is that I'm just
a genuinely curious person talking to
another person who knows a lot of things
that I can take an hour out and do and
um I think it ends up being pretty good
yeah and so you know yeah we haven't we
haven't we haven't had a full-on like
debate on on a podcast yet and haven't
figured out how I would even structure
that if we were to because I debate I
debate in my public life so often it's
like you know yeah I don't know he's
that or need to put it on the podcast
either but it bit but a lot of people
would like to watch it though yeah I
mean I think it would be nice because
you could be in a situation where
they're not look constrained by time if
you've got somebody else that was sane
yeah that had a different viewpoint on
this out of the other thing where you
could actually discuss and maybe make
some mutual forward progress between
right know coming to better ideas or
more mutually agreed upon ideas that
might be nice you are on Instagram at
Dan Crenshaw TX which is for Texas echo
in case you didn't know that Facebook
Dan Crenshaw at Dan Crenshaw and you
also have your website which is crunched
off for Congress is that where the book
is as well or no no no is the book the
book is game Crenshaw book calm got it
yeah like your branding it's just like
mine my name that's exactly now um did I
miss anything as far as like all this
all this stuff as far as getting in
touch with you and all that um no I mean
it's easy to find me on social media you
have to keep in mind here's some
annoyances about how my social media
works on Instagram I have one account
okay it's my personal account it's uh
it's not really official it's not really
campaign but the way the rules work you
have to generally differentiate between
official and campaign which is why
there's two Facebook accounts which is
why there's two Twitter
and you have to follow all of them to
get all the information Instagram if
you're an Instagram user it's a little
easier for you I just cuz I I control
that's my personal account and that's
that's why you just have to search for
me a couple times and then follow both
that's the only thing I would add got it
now Dan I know you're doing a lot for
America which is definitely appreciated
but I want you to know that we're doing
our part over here as well in the
private sector we're working hard to
make people better yes to make the
economy better and rebuild the
foundation of America or at least one
foundation of America that is
self-reliance and our ability to create
and build the best products in the world
100 percent american-made did I say a
hundred percent american-made yes yeah
100 percent american-made in three years
it's three years we've gone from eight
employees to 80 we are just getting
warmed up little company up in Maine is
my home state my home region I should
say I'm a New Englander yeah because I
got time in Connecticut and Maine but I
can I claim it a little bit my home a
record is made yes you can clean up
there we got a little factory we got
something called origin Maine tell us
about it echo Charles oh well oh by the
way we are getting softer by the way as
generally speaking as a group we are all
getting softer that's why generation
after generation they say oh my
generation was harder than this new
generation that's why they always say it
you're saying it factually it's
factually then this is why generally
speaking as individuals there's
variations and individuals for sure and
even little micro groups for sure
variation but this is why technology the
whole reason for technology is to solve
our problems mister make things easier
make everything easier exactly right and
and I'd say I like to look not like to
but I look at it as to solve our
problems which is making things easier
for sure so even like the caveman right
when they invented the wheel all these
softies they got the wheel now yeah I'm
saying because before uh that generated
like our generation we had to carry
stuff I mean there
gently harder I think objectively
speaking and that's not a bad thing that
we've made things easier but right but
you have to art is just kind of the
whole point of the chapter do something
hard you've got us it you have to make
up for that yeah you're artificially
yeah hardening your own life oh yeah and
that's why this is like your book is
good that's why what you say is good is
because right we can't this is a wave a
wave of just easiness coming on us
there's no stopping it but individually
we can kind of like fight against not
necessarily the wave but the results of
the wave yeah I'm saying you can do
something hard yeah so what you get
though what you will get inevitably is
everyone with all their problems solved
and we're always looking for these
little issues yeah because that's how
right that's nature so now it's like hey
that's some injustice right there yeah
it's a lot it's a lot harder to complain
about the injustice of your Wi-Fi in
your neighborhood not being as strong as
if you don't got food on your plate and
think about like your kids know right
where it's like oh yeah they got to wear
helmets now assume saying hey you guys
got to wear seatbelts now so I get into
like a 1965 something yeah right you're
gonna die in that thing it seems like
they seem saying but that was just how
back there yeah now getting your 2020
whatever Tesla and buy you can fall
asleep behind the wheel you're safe they
got you no problem exactly right all
your problems solved so that's how you
know it's like a you know the all these
groups of people might not like very
small groups of people but they're super
loud because they can be now that's just
how like back in the day because they're
not out hunting down elk
yeah the bow and arrow yeah and not to
mention the technology allows all this
you know so yeah and they're loud or
whatever but you make a good point where
it's like yeah if you go out and look
for all these issues it's like it's hard
to find them but your how you say like
Ben Shapiro and Dan there and Ground
Zero did you come man
Canada's otter get us better at ground
yeah so it's gonna seem pretty bad
nonetheless yes
so yes keep up the good fight against
the wait
a will doing hard things what hard
things you got for us echo trans what
can we do
jiu-jitsu hard daily heart hardships all
day daily hardships you know working out
Fitness jiu-jitsu and I was gonna say
fashion but that's more your oh that's
hard for you anyway so what'd you get -
what are we doing he didn't give we
didn't know ki noogie yeah if you get
Aggie get in or Jinky for all the
reasons you mentioned though yeah we'll
get you up to the factory up in Maine
dan you gotta go check it out it's um
it's awesome it's awesome
we literally brought the last bought the
last loom in Lewiston Maine from a five
hundred thousand square foot abandoned
factory that hadn't been used in 20
years and all the other hundreds and
hundreds of looms from that factory sent
overseas we're bringing it back we had
one loom now I think we got four looms
we're bringing it back an awesome and
you know the folks up there these are
folks that their industry was taken away
from them their industry was sold
overseas and now they're back craftsmen
crafts women sewing making boots making
jeans all in America from and every like
every single part of those jeans is
American yeah it this is such an
important I'm gonna bring it to a little
bit of politics and how I view this and
the need to to embrace some sense of
American economic nationalism which
we've lost over time and the the rise of
Trump when people ask about how the
Republican Party has changed under Trump
what they're it's usually a disingenuous
question what they want you to say is
that Republicans are racist right that's
really what they're insinuating when
they ask that question or that they're
more racist now it's not true that but
there is some change and this this drive
towards to to a conversation about
economic nationalism is actually part of
that change and it's been interesting to
watch and I think it's a necessary
change because what Trump got was a lot
of Democrat voters who may be voted
Democrat their whole life but they're
part of a union culturally speaking they
identify a hell of a lot more with me
than they do
AOC okay so they started voting based on
that but also Trump finally talked about
some things they were concerned about
which was like China
okay China taking advantage of us NAFTA
taking advantage of us and the reality
is that's it that's a nuanced
conversation it's not it's not it's
different for every factory to be honest
sometimes it's the business itself that
sucked
sometimes it is Chinese dumping that
occurred all right sometimes it's just
it's a mix of things but Republicans for
too long
adhere to a highly stringent free market
economy dogmatic approach which said if
another country can make it cheaper they
should make it all right that's just
that's economics 101 we're done no more
thinking about it
well that's it's not that simple like
there's winners and losers here just
because like tomatoes are now five cents
cheaper for everybody doesn't mean that
we're all better off you know we've of
farmers that no longer make tomatoes
also we don't make tomatoes and now by
the way again let's bring it back to
some coronavirus we've got a real
conversation in this country to have
about medical device manufacturing and
supply lines of our medical industry and
computer industry and everything else
like there is benefit even if it costs
us more there is benefit to having that
here in America it's real benefit not
just the job the manufacturing jobs are
certainly some of those benefits but
there's a national security reason as
well and it's about time we have a more
honest conversation about that as
Republicans Democrats will just be
against Trump no matter what so like
that because they don't rip them they're
not really principled in this that
they're mostly about seeking power for
the sake of the revolution again I could
go way back into that again but and and
so you know I we just I think that's an
interesting point this is where I want
to end that and so I love what you guys
are doing I guess is what I'm really
trying to say
yeah well it's and you know we got this
right now again you're talking
coronavirus we got 100% American supply
chain so zero impact is zero impact it's
it's just it's
it's awesome and yeah you're talking
about the the Chinese are making a bunch
of the what 95% the pharmaceuticals or
something crazy there's crazy number
like that yeah that's not okay that's
not okay and yeah if you save five cents
on something that's not okay when when
something happens even if it was even if
it was just a natural disaster that that
caused problems over there you know no
political anything that's a real problem
and to have single source for life
life-saving capabilities that's a bad
plan and hopefully we look back at this
coronavirus and we say hey I'm glad we
got a heads up I'm glad we got a free
lessons relatively cheap lessons learned
yeah about this so anyways up in Maine
doing it we're doing it we're doing it
right now we've been doing it and we're
gonna continue to grow we're gonna
continue to get out the best products
we're making supplements to
supplementation as as echo Charles likes
to call it sure from time to time so for
supplementation what joint supplements
very important by the way yeah
joints I should probably take some of
this yeah bro what do you do like if
your joints don't work yeah not much and
just get new ones yeah yep there is that
technology by the way yeah also Molk
Molk technically is supplementation
technically what is that more it's more
of a dessert it's a dessert that happens
to have a bunch of protein in it and
probiotics and it has no sugar that's
super healthy and it tastes delicious
technology I'm skeptical of the
delicious part that oh that's great
that's what's crazy that's what's crazy
that's what has got so many people
officially on the milk train I change so
much to say I will send you what's your
flavor of these flavors chocolate
vanilla mint chocolate chip which is my
personal favorite Reese's Peanut Butter
Cup and I know I can't call it that but
that's what it tastes like butter
chocolate peanut butter chocolate a big
fan of the peanut butter chocolate and
then here's the one that's kind of the
creeper or the the what's it called the
crea no the super the sleeper is
strawberry hmm so did you ever have
strawberry Quik when you were kid yeah
did you write it yes okay
I'm not kidding
I'm not kidding strawberry milk tastes
better than strawberry Quik no like a
competitive illiquid weight we can weave
back because it's my preference for
flavor does depend on the substance it's
like a milkshake milkshake milkshake a
milkshake order chocolate milk or a or a
Nestle's Quik okay well what you can
make pink is you can put more can pretty
much anything okay okay so based on the
fact that it's more like a milkshake
then I would yeah then I would I would
say not the peanut butter I do like
peanut butter milkshake but that's more
of an ice cream that I'm favored okay
so can we have milk ice cream is that a
thing we have things in in process for
the milk ice cream and we did did you
have some at camp yes sir okay
so yeah we we have multi scream we need
to move forward on our logistics that's
a heavy logistics you know you're
talking about shipping frozen fruits etc
so we're moving in that direction that
we're not there yet we're working on it
gotcha
it's a we have Mars coming we did
totally ridiculous yeah totally
ridiculous you don't change your stuff
so strawberry then yeah yeah the whole
the whole line so you'll just be you'll
become sometimes you can be the mood for
mints you know strawberry I've got a
sweet tooth oh yeah I smoke bars you
gonna it's funny cuz you know how kids
are the kind of a litmus test you know
like if you give the kid like let's say
back in the day right you got your diet
shake and then it's like it's yeah I
think it out you say you should give it
to the kid because like brown like this
like you know I I dig it or whatever
they don't just don't like so my and I
have a video of this where my son three
by the way which is a solid little test
create a good experiment
yeah yeah because he doesn't have morals
or nothing like that so he's just tell
you the truth yeah that's what I mean
like he didn't care about your feelings
or whatever so yeah I have a video of
him chomping a milk bar and I'm like I
didn't give him a milk bar and he's like
oh yeah he just called the chocolate bar
whatever and I was like what heating and
he's like yeah it's frozen chocolate bar
and here's the thing I put those in the
freezer to hide him and he went in there
right now with motivation obviously
insane taste buds is the number one
motor
factor in this case check anyway so that
was to the test that's my wire though I
don't want to get too ahead of myself
yeah yeah
stick with the mock for now um alright
so yes and by the way all those things
the supplementation the drinks
everything is available at origin mancom
also at Vitamin Shoppe nationwide there
you go
also we will be listing Dan's book for
easy availability fortitude on our
website chocolate podcast.com go ahead
click on the book section on the top
menu we have a book section there that's
my episode so this episode boom you'll
see you see Dan's book there anyway you
can get it there also in the store it's
called choco store so you go chocolate
store calm similar to Dan's book or what
was it called
fortitudo calm down Crenshaw book calm
calm yes in the simplicity same choco
store to store from choco choco store
right calm anyway this is where you can
get what shirts hats hoodies many
garments representative of the path the
path subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already which if you haven't
already you might want to just do a full
on sort of systems check of your whole
life otherwise just just subscribe check
out dance podcast which is called hold
these truths or you can just search for
Dan crunch on it pops up don't forget
about the grounded podcast I mean where
we talk about the most important things
in life all kind of related to another
thing in life called jiu-jitsu warrior
kid podcasts we're gonna have one with
Dan crunch on it by the way so your kids
can figure out how they want to be
directed down the path and don't forget
about that warrior kid soap from Irish
ocean ranch dot-com black soap which is
magically turns to cleanliness on your
body
yep counterintuitive for sure it's
called yes Dan question I have black
toothpaste debated charcoal activated
circle and it helps us some sort of
thing right
I know what it does yes but we know it's
cool Dane's my towel we know that it
looks cool so but it feels cleaner yeah
I like it so we got we got so that helps
to kill germs bacteria does not stick
around
yeah and that's hope it's called killer
soap and what that will do it will help
you and your family stay clean got a
YouTube channel yes video version of
this podcast and see what Dan Crenshaw
looks like good good looking guy it's
really good looking you know who
eyepatch new eyepatch by the way its new
yeah
just unveiled this one boom you don't
see what that looks like we have a
YouTube channel on YouTube youtube.com
etc you understand also some excerpts on
there by the way you don't watch the
whole if you don't forward to your
friend go hey hey check out what echo
Charles said about this and then they
send him a four hour what is it yeah for
our video video Eleanor didn't they help
anybody
oh man so part of the problem at that
point in life we got psychological
warfare on mp3 platforms we need a
little psychological creator you can get
it we got flipside canvas Dakota Meyer
my brother making cool things to hang on
your wall we got a bunch of books we got
fortitude by Dan Crenshaw we got
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual we got the way the warrior kids
series we got Mikey and the dragon we
got discipline equals freedom Field
Manual we got extremely ownership in the
dichotomy leadership get every single
one of those books yeah national on
front leadership consultancy what we do
is solve problems through leadership go
to echelon front comm if you need to
help at your business team corporation
we got you covered
EF online is online training for
leadership interactive check that out
mustard 2020 Orlando may 7th and 8th mmm
not so sure about that one we may be
getting some what do you think Dan what
do you think the chances are nine
hundred people I mean experts think you
know this is a change in America life
that'll last a month or two and then we
won't be on the downtrend we can look at
the numbers coming out of China and
South Korea as perhaps a guide is
you have the decrease in cases happens
hopefully we don't even reach the peaks
that they did mm-hmm
yet to be seen plus we got social
distancing slowing down the curve echo
st. e : basically if you've been hanging
around echo echo thinks that he's sort
of a national hero right now because
he's not he's not shaking people's hands
he's sort of taken on you know you're
talking about the arc typical hero I
think we had echo Charles over there
he's sacrificing his own
oh yeah hugs his own hugger or not
keeping it real
look if Orlando doesn't go down we'll
keep you posted but then it's going to
be Phoenix Arizona September 16th and
17th Dallas Texas December 3rd and 4th
and of course we have EF overwatch and
EF Legion if you need personnel inside
your business that understand the
principles that we talk about all the
time that we wrote about go to EF
overwash comm for executive leadership
from the military go to EF Legion comm
for frontline troops and leaders that's
what we do and if you still want to
interact with us some more which is just
getting kind of crazy I mean it's been a
long time there's a lot of hours but if
you need more then we are on the
interwebs Dan like I said Dan is on
Twitter and on Instagram at Dan Crenshaw
TX for Texas Facebook Dan Crenshaw
website Dan Crenshaw FERC and for
Congress echo and I are also there on
Twitter on Instagram and on good old
days epoch echos adequate Charles and I
am at doc look echo any closing thoughts
no good to see Dan Crenshaw again this
time this time has an esteemed member of
an esteemed ste big-time esteemed here
it's a lovely word hmm
I really appreciate it it's been fun
yeah little longer than we thought
you know we got a lot to say man some
tangental things but all good a and um
thanks for coming back on you know
thanks for sharing your life story and
your lesson so not just here but in the
book and I know people are gonna gonna
thank you for the book and I am gonna
thank you and everyone thanks you for
your service and your sacrifice
not only on the battlefield but now you
know you're fighting a different kind of
battle and you know you and I talk
offline I and I told you twice once on
the phone and once when you showed up
here I'm really glad that you have your
job and I have mine your job is not one
that I would want and not fun but you're
doing it for the right reasons and I
think everyone appreciates the fact that
you're fighting a battle for the future
of America so that said America remains
now and forever the land of the free and
the home of the brave and the same goes
to the rest of our servicemen and women
out there freedom is not free and
someone has to hold the line and it is
all of you soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines out there who keep evil and
darkness at bay and we thank you for
that and the same thing goes to our
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service
same thing freedom isn't free it takes
sacrifice and thanks to all of you for
what you do every day to take care of us
and keep our country free and everyone
else out there life is a struggle it's a
challenge it's suffering and you're not
always gonna win but even when you don't
win as Dan says don't quit don't give up
don't be a victim don't take the easy
path don't squander this life instead
live with fortitude by getting up every
day and getting after it and until next
time this is Dan Crenshaw and Necco and
Jocko out